solution for Humanity
peace peace is what we need for you and
me
peace the solution for Humanity
obese
[Music]
[Music]
open your eyes your heart your mind
seek the truth and you will find the day
is clear
from
night as darkness is
[Music]
[Music]
everybody
yes
[Music]
[Music]
foreign foreign
can you admit yourself
and we have the biggest online event of
the year with the All-Star lineup and
we're going to get right into it with my
next guest needs no introduction he is
the founder and Dean of the IOU Islamic
online university
and he's also published over
written translated published over 50
books he's no stranger to the D show
without further Ado let's bring out my
shake your shake Dr Bilal Phillips here
on the dean show
salaam alaikum
Shea how are you thank you for accepting
an invitation to be with us here on the
special occasion
my pleasure to be able to help in the
efforts
well we'll go ahead and let you take it
from here
foreign
and then all those who follow the path
of righteousness until the last day
the topic that I have chosen
to briefly share with you
is that of the importance of islamized
Education
first and foremost we need to understand
what is education
and there are many different definitions
of education but the one which for me
sums it all up
is the definition wherein it's stated
that education is the way by which a
civilization
transfers its culture to the Next
Generation
we're talking about the transfer of
culture
so education the facts and the figures
are wrapped in a package
of culture
so naturally because there is a distinct
difference between
Islamic culture
the culture of Muslims
when practiced according to the
teachings
and
other cultures that are around in the
world
and the dominating culture right now is
that of
Western Civilization sculpture
that's reality
now what do we do with that reality as
Muslims whether we live within
America
UK
Canada
Western countries France Etc
or
we live in Muslim countries that are not
necessarily implementing Islamic law
across the board
to varying degrees
the educational process is ongoing
and for the West
Western Civilization
they have chosen to go secular
basically to remove religion from
education and the process of Education
and in that removal
they have removed morality from
education
so all the subjects we study we study
them without any moral compass guiding
us
we just study the facts and the figures
and we get the skills Etc to get out
after graduation to work within the
system and earn a living for ourselves
vacations
holidays retirement
Etc
however
as the prophet sallam said
each and every one of you is a Shepherd
responsible for his or her flock
and then he went into the details of the
husband and the wife and the family Etc
but the main point here is that the
children that we raise
they have a right
who islamized education
that's their right
and if we don't give it to them we will
be asked
foreign
[Music]
each and every one of you is a Shepherd
Like a Shepherd
responsible for his or her flock we will
be asked about how we looked after the
flock which was put under our
responsibility and control
so raising up our children especially
those of us who are in
living in
Western Civilization
there are many many challenges
what is being taught in the schools
across the West
in many instances go against
Islamic teachings
so we as Muslims are obliged if we are
going to live in the west we are obliged
to develop an alternative
an alternative way to convey the facts
and the figures
but in an Islamic cultural package
where morality is
embedded
from the very first day
so this
is
a look at education
as a responsibility which we all carry
for ourselves as well as for our
children
which requires us
to integrate
Islamic teachings into the various
Sciences departments Etc you know
where people specialize all of the
various subjects whether mathematics
science
uh geography whatever
Islamic
principles and teachings should be
integrated and of the most important
is that of morality because Prophet
Muhammad himself said
I was only sent to perfect for you the
highest of moral character traits
so the prophet saws summed up the whole
message of Islam in
the one word morality
worshiping Allah is morally good
worshiping other than Allah is morally
bad
being kind to other human beings is
morally good being evil to other human
beings is morally bad
being destructive to the
environment that we live in is morally
bad
and being protective is morally good and
so on and so forth
that Islamic morality
which is not to say in it's Unique in
the sense that people don't know this is
good and bad and now of course
Islam didn't bring new good that people
didn't know for the most part
for the most part it's the same good but
the point is that it is connected with
belief in God
and introduce into all subjects which
are taught in school
and as such
it is then
our duty
to develop Islamic schools
worse students have the opportunity to
be exposed to Modern
knowledge modern
Advanced civilizations
products
but to be exposed from an Islamic
perspective this is what is required
so
considering this responsibility
Muslims in different parts of the West
and the East have set up Islamic schools
or what we call Islamic schools but of
course there are principles that govern
what an Islamic school should be
and we have to be
particularly careful
to ensure that the necessary components
of what makes up an Islamic school
are in place
so we in fact convey to our students
the teachings of Islam from tawheed
the Oneness of Allah that he alone
deserves to be worshiped all the way to
Clarity zakah fasting all the other
principles of Islam right on
to
kindness gentleness
in dealing with our each other
Islam is the religion of peace
the religion of Adam
the one religion which
Allah
chose for human beings
as he chose one set of human beings
to live in this world
and he created for them this one world
he created one religion
and that religion begins with tawheed
the Oneness of Allah
so
in order to achieve this goal
the dean show
has been active in trying to develop in
Florida
the dean Center
and that Dean Center
has in it a recording studio to
prepare and develop and and and
distribute
they didn't show segments
alhamdulillah
keep it going strong it also has
athletic
facilities
for young people children to play it
also has within it a Masjid
full-fledged Masjid
and most importantly
it has an Islamic school
they have
importantly included the Islamic school
as a key element in the dean Center
so my brothers and sisters we ask you
to share in this good
be a part of this good
by supporting donating
providing whatever help we can give
to make this Dean Center a reality
for Muslims in America
and as an example for Muslims around the
world
[Music]
all right Dr Bala Phillips thank you
very much may Allah the almighty rewards
you thank you for being with us and all
your support
I got one more person who's going to
give salaams special guests here you
know him I know him we know him
abdulrahim green can you give salams to
the share before he leaves
hahaha
we can't hear you I'll mute your mic oh
assalamu alaikum I'm really sorry yeah
thanks for the reminder Chef uh
on point as always
check how come you look younger I see
you how do you do that
foreign
and my next guest coming up no stranger
to the dean show
is Sheikh Abdul Rahim green but before
we bring him on let's have a word with
Dr Hafiz Imam assalamualaikum
you know the message message resonate
that he has spoken entered into our
hearts it is the time for our action
inshaallah all the brains all the
intellectuals all the scholars all
across the globe are supporting this
noble cause it is our time to support
them inshallah and say to their
investment
opportunity that they're offering us
support the dean Center Dean Center is
about to become a reality which has been
the dream of many of us I would like to
urge you all to do whatever you can
inshaallah can I urge you all on the
statement that the Dr Philippe has said
make the donation inshallah we are
looking for donations as small as even a
dollar it's a Baraka that we need to
start out with everybody out there can
do everything the link is already there
on the comment side I would like to to
go and log in and support but inshallah
while you're all doing all you can I
would like to appeal to those
individuals who could give us ten
thousand dollars fifteen thousand twenty
five if you can if Allah bless you now
is the time to do it it is the
opportunity that you could invest with
Allah and deposit in the Hereafter Bank
this is the opportunity and if you even
if you can give one thousand dollar one
hundred dollar do it inshallah can I
have at least two or three brothers
giving one thousand dollar each
inshallah one thousand dollar each
inshallah
let me see on the comments box inshallah
if you can do that I would like for you
all to get the word out to your friends
relatives let them log in let them
listen to it and you never know who
Allah will guide to participate in the
beautiful noble cause
and we'll be having to share green also
speaking while you're listening to the
[ __ ] says
and our hearts and our wallets will open
for this noble cause may Allah make it
easy Allah
thank you let's bring out Sheikh Abdul
rahima green here on the dean shall go
ahead take it away Sheikh
Islam alaikum um brothers and sisters
assalamu alaikum everyone
um
let me just flip my camera maybe that
will be better okay yes brothers and
sisters listen I don't know much about
you know uh Eddie's Center I've
obviously watched a little bit of things
uh here and there and been keeping up
with what Eddie's been doing I've known
Eddie
um subhanallah I don't know how long
since he started his amazing work and I
want to say this is this is really what
has to be said to everybody
the work that Eddie has been doing for
years now probably coming on to decades
maybe 20 years I don't know he'll tell
us how long he's been doing it for uh
this is
very important work
this is groundbreaking work that he's
been doing
um and I don't think that there can't be
that many people in the English-speaking
world who haven't I mean of the Muslim
English-speaking word world who haven't
heard of Eddie and have not watched at
least some of his programs uh the dean
show
but one of the things that I think is
maybe one of the most important things
brothers and sisters and you know I know
maybe these days I come across maybe as
a bit of a broken record and I keep
saying the same things over and over
again because I think they're very
important and that's why I emphasize it
and that's why I stress on it and this
is the whole subject of inviting
non-muslims to Islam
and one of the things that I do feel
um is that unfortunately the Muslim
ummah has become so obsessed with itself
almost narcissistic
in the sense that we're so wrapped up in
our own problems we're so wrapped up in
our own concerns and for very good
reasons
um especially for Muslims living in the
west we are struggling a lot we are
seeing we are losing our children
just yesterday a brother found me
um and his 11 year old son
who is in the US of a
um is saying that he feels like he's
bisexual and that the Quran is made up
this is the sort of thing that many of
us are encountering encountering
um even people who come from Pious
families whose
fathers and mothers are practicing
Muslims sometimes even Imam sometimes
even Scholars
and it's very tempting to think that the
solution to these things lies in
becoming even more inward
um retreating even further from society
trying to isolate ourselves even more
from all of these things but personally
I don't think that that is an effective
long-term strategy I don't even think
it's going to be particularly effective
in the short term but in the long term
it's it's probably really not going to
work out that well
what do I think will work out and I'm
not saying that we won't lose people on
the Wayside I'm not saying that people
you know we won't lose some of our
children but what I do believe that is
if we have a dour mindset if we have a
mindset that we are the people with the
Cure we are the people who have the
guidance from Allah and this guidance
from Allah can enable us to transform
not only people's lives individually but
to transform people's lives collectively
and we only need to see
the mess that is happening in the world
today when it comes to economics when it
comes to the rising the astronomical
rises in prices of fuel of the cost of
living of many different things of
inflation which is just another way in
which people are robbed of their money
because in reality what it means is that
whatever you're earning actually buys
less that's what really it means because
the worth of your money
is just it's not worth as much you can't
do as much with it which means in effect
you are poorer and the thing is that we
know that Islam has real practical
solutions for these issues we see
divisions in society we see Society
breaking down in so many different ways
and again
we know as Muslims that Islam has
Solutions in fact Islam is the only
real solution for these problems
and it's you know it's a slogan we hear
this slogan a lot Islam is the solution
and unfortunately in some ways that's
what it's become it's become a slogan
and you know we love to say it but
unfortunately many of us don't live it
and even more unfortunately many of us
are not really skilled or capable of
explaining to people and conveying the
message to people as to how and why
Islam is a solution
but one thing we have to say about Eddie
and one thing we have to say about the
dean show is that is what he has
consistently done week after week after
week show after show off the show he has
tried to show non-muslims in a very
beautiful very approachable
manner
not only the errors of their ways but
the beauty of Islam
and this attitude this mindset this way
of thinking imagine if our children when
they went to these non-muslim schools
when they went out into society
they did that with the mindset with the
understanding not of some inferiority
complex not of the idea that somehow
they are living at the behest of this
super Advanced civilization
but rather understanding that although
the West may have achieved some things
materialistically they are lacking many
things spiritually mentally even
materialistically
and the Islam is a solution for the real
problems that people have in their
everyday lives whether it is stress
whether it is worry whether it is
economic problems whether it's social
problems mental problems so many of
these things division uh of so-called
races and color
Islam has and will deal with these
things
but unfortunately very very few Muslims
have taken up the mantle of doubt and
that is the only reason I am right here
right now
talking to you brothers and sisters and
participating
in this event that Ellie has organized
the real reason I'm here right now is
because I know that Eddie is someone who
cares very deeply very profoundly about
inviting and calling
non-muslims to Islam
and I am very very convinced I believe
very firmly that one of the big one of
the main causes
of the mess that we find ourselves in as
a nation as an ummah is that by and
large unfortunately we have abandoned
this obligation of dawah we do we do not
give this obligation
of inviting humanity is to Islam we do
not give this obligation of inviting
Humanity to Islam we do not give it the
priority we do not give it the
importance
that it deserves
just the other day my son was telling me
Oh Abba you need to go to America
martial law they have fantastic
communities there they're really really
sorted out
etc etc
and I said you know what probably if I
go there I'll just get upset and I'll
just get angry he said no why you know
it's just amazing I said well let me ask
you a question what's their dowel like
how good they are
how good are they at talking to
non-muslims about Islam
they weren't quite he said well yeah
maybe there's not that much of that
okay and when I say dawa I mean you know
I don't mean Interfaith work
right I don't mean you know
um
social work
um I don't mean you know
um advocacy I don't mean
um you know just joining hands with
various groups and various people I'm
not saying that type of work is not
important because I'm not saying that
but let's not pretend it's now
Dao is calling people to tow Heat
that is what dawah is inviting people
clearly
and unambiguously to Islam
as Eddie does as Eddie does when we see
it in the dean show you see him doing
that we see him inviting people he's
always inviting people always he takes
the time to invite people either to be
Muslim or to find out more about Islam
that's one of the reasons I love Eddie
that's one of the reasons I love his
show and that's one of the reasons I'm
supporting his work and that's the one
of the reasons that I'm I'm encouraging
everybody else to support what he does
because I know that what he does will
have that element that key element for
me it is key uh without that key element
of Dao being very prominent being highly
prominent I don't think that
there is going to be long-term successes
unfortunately what we'll end up doing is
building What I Call You Know Rich
ghettos
this is what I said to my son is it
maybe that's what it's like in America
you know everyone just isolates himself
and you have a rich ghetto I mean it's
it's a ghetto but it's just with lots
more money you know people are well
often they drive nice cars but they
still leave these lead these isolated
lives right and when I say isolated I
mean and it's strange that subhanallah I
remember one of our teams went to
America and they went out and they went
on the streets and they were giving Dao
and people were saying to them where
have you been
why haven't you done this before where
why aren't you out there talking to us
and telling us about Islam it's just so
good to see you people out here telling
us about what your religion is about I
you know
you have so many freedoms we have so
many possibilities and so many freedoms
living in the west but unfortunately
we don't make use of them but I know
that Eddie is one person I feel really
confident that not only has he done and
he will continue to do that because he
has the same passion that I have
he has the same concerns that I have so
brothers and sisters may Allah bless you
for listening insha Allah please support
Eddie please support the dean show
please support the new center because
I'm sure it's going to be
a center for calling people to Layla
which ultimately is the job of all the
prophets as Allah said
which means that Allah did not send to
Any Nation a messenger except that he
called the people to worship Allah alone
and reject the worship of the false gods
brothers and sisters
keep watching
you really hid the nail you know when
you talk about dawa is not is an
obligation many have taken as a optional
thing and you really brought the point
back to this obligation and it is the
duty that everyone of us have to take
care of it and if we cannot do it
individually we have got to at least
support those individuals and
organizations who are doing the job for
us in this absolutely that you have that
is doing this job and we need to support
Eddie in any shape and form
Allah reward you I mean I mean bring the
best in us
dear brothers and sisters out there
you've heard the Sheikh Sheikh is
talking about from his experience the
words were coming out directly from his
heart
this is the moment this is the reality
we really need to live up to the
requirement that we have as a Muslims
dawah is a must
and this is the best way to support this
inshallah so I would like to also
request everybody to understand that we
can accept donations through credit card
online you can go online click on the
link and support us or you can mail in
your checks as well and local brothers
and sisters here in U.S you could also
sell it or send any other shape or form
that you know how to get the money but
the money is needed time is of great
Essence at this time and we need to make
sure that we raise the needed funds in
order to bring this dream into reality
the dean Center
you know scholar said that if Allah like
what you do he might give you another
opportunity and that is a sign of your
act and Good Deeds being accepted
Allah blessed brother Eddie with the
dean show
with the dean so he was able to reach
Millions
single-handedly
so wisely addressing the Islamic phobics
clearing the misconception inviting
people to the true Islam like Dr Green
was saying and also
giving the dawah which is Our obligation
Allah granted acceptance to this work to
the degree now Allah has trusted him
from Dean's show to Dean Center
from the dean Center will be able to
call 300 million Americans to Islam
and your participation in this regard
will go a long way for generations to
come will benefit from it
if we only understand and realize the
need and the importance and the depth of
this cause you need not anybody to tell
you that you need to donate right now so
I would urge you all to do whatever you
can to participate in any shape and form
and every little bit counts it is not
the dollar that you donate that matters
it is the taqwa that comes from your
heart that matters and your support so
inshallah I urge you all to give
whatever you can go online and talk
about it and give so others can be
encouraged by your giving and you will
also get the share from it so inshallah
any amount one thousand three thousand
five thousand ten thousand please do it
do it now don't just think that okay I
will donate shaytan will convince you
not to do it again later nor when you're
feeling you want to give discharge it
before it is too late inshallah we have
another guest who's ready to inshallah
encourage us to do this Noble job
accepted from all of us
I cannot hear Eddie you need to unmute
we're we got an R star lineup thank you
thank you shakes for coming on and I'm
going to keep we're running a little bit
behind so don't worry we got the Sheikh
Hamza use uh I'm sorry say house at the
back and Shake Osama here with us Shake
we're running a little bit behind uh
we're gonna jump in with Sheikh Osama
and then we got Hamza zorcist my brother
Hamza source is coming up next how are
you go ahead and take it away
alhamdulillah
foreign
in fact uh
and when we talk about dawa I'm always
thinking about the seed when we want to
plant a seed we have to know the soil
and the nature of this soil what we need
to improve this soil what fertilizer we
need to get a good healthy plant
and the soil of the dawa is the word
it's the people in the humanity
and if we look at the world around us
nowadays we find that the world are
suffering suffering economically
suffering politically suffering socially
and so on
and this happened
as as a direct
reason of controlling of one uni
Paradigm of the people which is a
western paradigm
we are not talking only about the West
about the other countries all other
civilization are being affected
negatively by controlling of this
Paradigm on us ask any youth anywhere
what is the definition of success you
will find the answer all materials when
you talk about Freedom you only talk
about many things you can find this
Paradigm control even Muslim Societies
in Muslim countries so we are in front
and facing
urea and challenging in in tawa and in
our life
and when I travel around the world you
know I always find the people complain
from the same thing demolition
of the societies even in a big and and
rich countries like Japan like Korea all
of them losing their their identity for
a benefit of that this Paradigm now why
we are talking about these things
because we reach the what what is the
solution where is the alternative when I
look I find the only the only religion
on Earth qualified
to give alternative the humanity for the
humanity to save the humanity is Islam
to save the family which you start to to
be diluted you know every every thing in
our society starts to be lost
and it reached the other countries not
only in the west so I consider you in
the west is in the front line actually
you are not only making Dao in America
you are making dawa for the humanity
because America is the one who
transferred this Paradigm to the rest of
the world so you are in the middle you
are there
so let me show you my my experience and
my what I did in some countries in in
dollar so I start to contact ngos I
start non-muslims
and they start to to see the communities
and what what problems they have what
social problem they have and I offer the
Islamic solutions for it you know of
course I make it brief but it needs a
lot of of work
and amazingly amazingly that I found a
lot of good responses and I am not
hiding I am Muslim I have the solution
I will cut a conversation with one
journalist he told me you want to
promote social uh value uh Islamic
values I told him do you have economical
problem he said yes you you try to get
solution from the West right or from
China yes you have a traffic problems
yes I you you get some solution from
Japan said yes I told him you have
a social problems said of course said we
have the solution nobody asks you to be
Japanese ask you to be Western to take
their solution take my solution the guy
Shake hand with me and we start to work
in many uh social works as a Muslims and
we are telling them we have the
solutions and it was amazing results
so what I am looking for Dean uh Center
you know Dean shop was unique and I am
looking for redeemed Center to be unique
too
to solve these problems to be a place
you know to introduce Islam to the
others that's good that's very good to
be Lighthouse to the society to let the
Muslims in their society as add value
not versus each other how me as a Muslim
can be add value to the place I am
living in how I can help in stopping
drugs or the stomach crimes in stopping
abusing of child or children or or all
other problems because others cannot
give these Solutions the other thing I'm
looking for and this one of the
challenges we face in Darwin the
division of the Muslim and tag each
others and even it reached a public
debates I Muslim against Muslim is
something maybe some of you don't know
it but we saw it in some countries and
some countries where the Muslims are
minorities
so we need to learn how to disagree in
in in a proper way
how to to to when we disagree how to
accept the disagreement and how to look
for the comment between us and I
inspired you know you know by the Quran
when he said how to deal with non-muslim
or Alex
when we talk to the other uh societies
until they'll come to the human value to
Common value and this is what Islam
giving it works a lot so the other thing
I'm looking for for uh Dean Center is
what after shahada for the new Muslims
many of us working in Darwin and less
working in what we do for the new Muslim
to enable them to face the the life and
to be a good that is also now
many in dollar when we talk about our
work and our many I hear them saying we
want to share
and when we tell them come to share they
have no time it is the time now
shared by your money
you will take the whole reward
with us with with Eddie with everybody
working in down
let us save the humanity of what is
going on let us raise up the Islamic
Paradigm to save these Generations
coming to generation and we can do that
inshallah Allah I believe
the humanities the call
save
help each other and inshallah
all of us with you inshallah till we
find that a real Center
Library fig library now is the time dear
viewers please
support this noble cause as the Sheikh
has said this is the cause of Muslims
and one very important point the Sheikh
brought to our attention What Muslim
American does matters and affects the
rest of the world if we understand Our
obligation here we can be impactful for
the rest of the world in a very positive
manner there is no one out there who can
paint a very positive picture of ours
other than when we assume the
responsibility and in order for us to do
this job effectively we need to have
this Dean Center become a reality so I
urge you all to do whatever you can
inshallah to support now is the moment
to do it I really would like to see
online our people can go and support
this I have now mashallah text messaging
internationally people are watching Dean
show live and have many people
internationally known brother Eddie of
the dean show for years and they've been
following game and the interview that he
has done been used in many parts of the
world I would like to appeal every
corner of the globe
to extend your support in any shape and
form to bring the dean Center into
reality
this and I want every single one of you
to support Eddie from the dean show
financially and otherwise but in what
way
I want you to support his new project
the dean center it's going to be a
transformative experience this Center
why because it's going to be a Masjid
it's going to be a place of worship it's
also going to have Fitness facilities
and it's also going to be a dollar
Center to call people back to Allah
Muslims and non-muslims and we trust
Eddie completely I for one would take a
thousand bullets for Eddie he has a
vision he has more than 15 years of
experience in the tower he's had a huge
success with the dean show and he has
the support of many Duart and preachers
and Scholars from all around the world
it's going to be an amazing project for
everybody go to the dean center.org
donate now
[Music]
hmm
without further delay my brothers and
sisters my brother your brother hamza's
horses take it away Jake how are you I'm
sorry
how you doing alhamdulillah
makes other people smile
Bella make you smile on the day of
judgment inshallah I mean I mean when I
heard those thousand bullets brother
that melted my heart alhamdulillah
may Allah bless you too thank you
brother so what I have to say brothers
and sisters and friends is very clear
and it's very important the first thing
I would like to say is that when we look
at the work of brother Eddie over 15
years of experience with the YouTube
channel and all the other great work
that he's done this has shown
consistency and what's extremely
important in building trust with the
community is to be consistent and to be
honest I'm not aware of anyone more
consistent than Eddie from a dollar
context the Miller bless him and
preserve him and from this I want to
Anchor off on a very important point
where the reason we have to support the
dean Center
there are many reasons but one key
reason I want to talk about is the i in
the Quran when Allah says verse 33
and who is better in speech than the one
who calls to Allah does righteousness
and says indeed I am one of those who
submit now this Ayah for me is a kind of
a holistic approach to the Dao Allah is
telling us who we must become and what
things we have to have in place in order
to effectively give doubt to be of the
people who are praised by Allah meaning
that Allah is saying that those who are
better in speech are the ones who call
to Allah are the ones who do good deeds
are righteous and they say that I am one
of the Muslims so let's break this down
so Allah says that those who call to
Allah call to tawheed and we know not
only from Eddie's work but because of
his amazing vision for the center that
he is going to be calling people to
tawheed to the Oneness of Allah
to affirm his Oneness and also to know
Allah to love Allah to obey Allah to be
humble before him to fear Allah and to
direct and single out all acts of
worship to Allah Allah the internal acts
of worship and the external acts of
worship this is what the center is going
to be doing he's going to be calling
people to Allah making that direct quote
the second thing the second thing that
the Ayah talks about is righteousness
that there are people of righteousness
and we know that the dean Center is
going to be facilitating this
righteousness not only in speech calling
people to this righteousness but there's
righteous people facilitating this
project I don't want to throw dust in
the face of the founders of the
organizers but we know throughout the
consistency that righteousness
righteousness is there not only in
behavior and conduct and the way they
interact with the Best Manners but also
what they call to as well so there's
going to be that righteousness and the
other thing is what Allah tells us and
they say that I am one of those who
submit they say that they are those who
submit to Allah in essence they are
connecting the righteousness to tawheed
to Iman to the fact that they connect
themselves with Allah and they believe
in Allah so all the great activities and
actions whether it's the fitness
facilities whether it's helping those in
need whether it's counseling services or
it's all the amazing things that are
going to be happening in the dean center
it's going to be connected back to Allah
and his messenger it's going to be
connected back to tahid so what am I
saying here what I'm saying here is
the dean Center is going to be
implementing holistic Tower as per the
words of Allah
they call to Allah they do righteousness
and they say I am one of the Muslims
they connect that righteousness to their
submission to Allah because remember let
me just remind you what does Allah say
and who is better in speech than the one
who calls to Allah tawheed the one who
is righteous does righteousness and the
one who says that I am one of those who
submit and what's interesting here from
a tadabra point of view when Allah is
saying that they say that I am one of
those who submit it could also mean that
I'm just any other like any other Muslim
because sometimes when we get involved
in the dawah we could get arrogant we
can say it's all about me but we've seen
from the work of Eddie we've seen of the
Bulls who support him and we've seen
what the vision is for this Center is
that it's not going to be like that it's
going to bring the community to get
together we are the ones to submit to
Allah there's no arrogance here so the
reason I wanted to frame it in this race
to show you that if you're going to
support anything brothers and sisters
support a project that implements
holistic dawa they call to tawheed they
call to Allah they are righteous and
they say I'm one of the Muslims they
connect the actions to Iman and this is
exactly what Allah tells us in the 41st
chapter in the 33rd verse which is
absolutely phenomenal so if I were to
give money I wanted to give money and
yes inshallah I make a commitment to
support this as well inshallah after the
the the what do you call it the the live
I'm gonna go on the link and I'm going
to donate myself and I'm not just saying
that just to say like you know uh you
know don't show off my D's but it's to
encourage you that I'm not just here as
a speaker I'm here as a supporter as
well and I'm gonna also walk the walk
and give a donation I want every single
one of you to donate as well because
this is this Dean Center is going to be
implementing an amazing eye of the Quran
which is holistic Dao now what's very
interesting is the Ayah that follows
that is phenomenal verse 34. Allah says
good and evil are not the same repel by
that which is better and between two
people there's any enmity or hatred it
would turn into intimate friendship
this is such a beautiful Ayah and this
is Allah is telling us how we must
become in the dawah as well what does
righteousness really mean is to have him
to have forbearance to to emulate the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam and
we've seen through the consistent since
you have Eddie's work and we've seen
from the vision of this Center is to
have people who are people of haleem of
Helm or forbearance when there are
islamophobes or haters that you repel by
that which is better what do the earlier
say repelling by that which is better is
repenting by that which is more virtuous
and more beautiful we need to be Muslims
of virtue and of beauty and this is
exactly part of the strategy of the dean
Center so how can you go wrong the dean
Center is a manifestation of
verse 33 and verse 34.
and it's very hard to find centers like
this and we need this especially in
North America to make that much needed
impact and that's why it's not just
bricks it's not just pastel and mortar
it's not just cement you are supporting
a vehicle that's going to express and be
an embodiment of sort of fossil at verse
33 and verse 34 brothers and sisters how
can you go wrong how can you go wrong
and just finally I want to add this very
clearly for you to understand
when you support the Dao brothers and
sisters the reward is phenomenal now we
should never compare between
humanitarian efforts and our efforts we
we need both but if if
there was no choice and you had to
choose one or the other and this is what
I believe in you support the Dao why
because when you support the dawah you
facilitate people you can become a
Muslim those Muslims are going to have
Iman inshallah and they're going to also
give sadaqa they're also going to
support other Dow organizations they're
also going to support humanitarian
organizations so supporting the dawah is
supporting everything because you
increase the amount of people and you
create people with Iman by the will and
mercy of Allah
and all of that is yours so imagine the
dean Center and I know this is possible
because we've seen it before the dean
said to get a thousand shahadas a month
in a year they get 12 000 shahadas a
year they have a new Muslim program that
takes care of all of these shahadas
just look think about the the reward
it's mind-boggling because your donation
that support these 12 000 shahadas a
year
each of these twelve thousand shahadas
inshallah they're going to be praying
because there's new Muslim support
they're going to be fasting they're
going to be reading Quran they're going
to be giving sadaka and you're going to
get a shame all of the reward based on
the Hadith which
I'm paraphrasing that if you call
someone to something good you will get a
share in that reward as well so think
about the mind-boggling numbers it's
beyond anything you can imagine twelve
thousand shahadas means you get the road
of all a sharing the road about all of
their prayers their sadaka their good
deeds and if they get married that makes
it 24 000 if they have two kids each
that makes it 48 000 people and you get
the shame the reward of all of their
good deeds and that is just in this
generation imagine the generations to
come all of that subhaka for you just by
supporting the dawa you can't go wrong
brothers and sisters everything I've
mentioned so far is it should be enough
and with Iman it should be enough so dig
deep
the trust is there the vision is there
the holistic Tower is there and the
reward is there how can you go wrong
donate now now I'm telling you okay
tonight now
please this how else can I do it if I
could shake you and tell you I'll shake
you look I'm shaking the phone
donate now all right well obviously
every single one of you I love Eddie uh
as I said I'll take a thousand bullets
for him may not preserve him and his
family and Allah preserve every single
one of you
thank you so much for being with us
taking the time and we're gonna meet
inshallah next time we got a Shay from
Bosnia here we wanted you before you
leave we got shade golosh here from
mustar when you were in Bosnia uh Hamza
did you visit mostar
I think so I don't remember that's where
the bridge the bridge is where they do
the jumping off the bridge yes yes I
went there this is the this is the Shea
who jumps off the bridge
so uh inshallah when you visit this is
uh uh this is the Mufti from mustard
well I've got both of you you too Shane
all right I'll talk to you soon
and our next guest coming up here take
it away we got Sheikh golish all the way
from Bosnia
foreign
first of all I have to say that my uh
this is my first speech in English and
my English is not so good
so because of that I apologize for any
possible mistakes in my speech but I
hope hope that you will understand me
uh I want to take thank brother Eddie
for inviting inviting me to take a part
in this event
and also our brothers speakers before me
they mentioned so many useful things
uh in this few minutes I will talk about
a few things which I consider very
important
first is importance and value of dawa I
think that already most of us know so
much about these things
but we have to remind ourselves about
that
uh I would say that very often one we
when we are doing Java or talking about
Java
uh we are not so uh aware of importance
and value value of it
I think that will uh I think we will
best understand it if we imagine for
example uh a man who is very very sick
and he feel pain
uh what what a big pain or feel pain for
uh for many years
and after that uh
he's going he got into to the doctor and
after he is cured uh can we imagine her
his happiness on or how many happy is
that mean
uh someone who lives uh without real
belief
in fact he lives with pain
so one of really meaning of Dava is that
we are helping people
to lose their pain and suffering
so many people here in Balkan and maybe
next time we can talk about that about
accepting Islam in Balkan
in Bosnian Croatia and Serbia so many of
them they asked me why are you inviting
us to Islam for example they say we are
believers we believe in one God but why
are you inviting us to Islam so I like
to say
I like to say I like to answer to them
saying I mean I'm inviting you because I
wish you all the best
I'm not inviting you because I hate you
because like we believe uh we believe
that we have to believe in one God in
all Prophet prophets including Jesus and
Muhammad so can we be in Paradise
so I'm inviting you because I wish to
you to be with uh with uh to be with us
in Paradise
uh so if we see the mission of all
Prophets
uh was inviting people to Islam economic
Jesus
and Jesus for example uh he didn't say
to to Jews or people look guys I'm
Prophet it's very good to be a prophet
if you want to send follow me you can
follow me if you don't follow me it's no
problem we can be in Paradise there
again something like that no he say to
them God sent me you say to them you
have to follow follow me if you follow
me you will be with me
but also what I want to mention uh what
we can find in gospels if it's true
that Jesus say to his students and I
will make you Fishers of Men
I think it's in Matthew
chapter four I I will make you Fishers
of Men the meaning of that is I will
teach you how to invite people to the
true
so because of that we are inviting
people to to God to worship one God to
follow the the prophets and all of of of
uh basic things basic things in Islam uh
I I uh also I will mention when I from
Quran
foreign
who was dead and we gave him life
in this Ayah Allah
tell us that one who does don't have
true belief in fact he
in fact he he has not he has not alive
so can we understand how we can
understand that we can understand that
if
now for example we have one who doesn't
know what is he from who is he is
creative Creator maybe he know what his
his name his whole name like in passport
but he don't know uh what is he from who
is his creator what is he going what is
the after the after the life
I think I think that this question what
is after life this life what's after
death that is one uh hardest uh and most
big uh most difficult question in uh in
this Dunya in this life even for biggest
philosophers in the history of human
being
what is coming after life
so uh so many people or most of people
they are not taking what what is coming
after life because they don't know what
is coming after life so they are so
afraid or they are confused but we know
because we Hawaii we have a Quran we
have Sunnah we have tradition so our
fear manifest in preparing for the day
for hisab for day of judgment
uh uh also uh here I can mention okay
okay uh because of time I will uh only
say uh
the same Ayah Allah
foreign
how to make difference between uh
difference uh between true and false we
can say that one of the meaning is how
to make a relationship with another's
how first of all how to make a relation
a relation with his God after that after
that how we can make relation a
relationship with another people with
his parents with his friends with his
children and other people so uh uh I uh
only will mention that the Islamic
Legacy is most richest Legacy we can
find and I think that this is one kind
of the Quran that for example
immigrationity in Judaism we cannot find
so many texts about
about for example about the class and
things like this and I will finish
because of time my speech that
importance of Dava and
like as I say that is helping people how
to live hair fields and uh
the uh their pains all this data this
data have to be organized it's very this
very important thing so we uh we are
reading in the Sierra that Prophet
Muhammad
the first thing he did uh when he
entered to Medina he built the Masjid
the Masjid in that time was like Islamic
Center in our time
in the fact uh uh this is chance for all
of us to help brother Eddie to make uh
to finish his Islamic Islamic Center
this is a chance for us to do something
what will be happy for that in the day
in the day of uh in the day of judgment
inshallah
Islamic Center in an organized way you
really send the message across Jeff you
said this is your first speech in
English
out there must be thinking I have never
supported our work just like you never
spoken in English if you do also support
I can guarantee you this will be the
best feeling that you will have support
is
actually wanna after I learned Arabic I
forgot English and also Norwegian but
uh maybe after maybe it will be reason
and to to make me to to repeat my my
English only just a seconds I will say
that I know brother Eddie
very very good because he's from Boston
and she's coming to Bosnia and when it
comes to Bosnia spelling sometime with
him so brother Eddie's is is the person
either who who who live uh who like who
love and also he leave the dawah he
lived
he's leaving the dial I have some
stories with with him I don't want to
talk about that because it will be talk
with uh in his face
on the next show inshallah
thank you very much and I'm very pleased
for talking uh taking part in this event
so
please come forward and support we would
like to see the numbers on the screen
brothers and sisters I know we can make
this a reality inshallah be part of it
where Allah and his Malai can write in
our account as a donors the previous you
know speakers and a lot of lines of
Scholars who are supporting this noble
cause that is beyond anybody's doubt
whether it is a good cause or not this
is the moment to do whatever you can
inshallah
okay
I think you're on mute brother or Daddy
thank you for being with us here and
inshallah we get All-Star line up there
he's been wanting to put something
together in Bosnia so we get Jake
McCarthy we got Muhammad hijab coming up
we gotta uh we gotta All-Star crew Shea
McCarthy sorry to keep all you guys
waiting we're we're got a whole line
All-Star lineup in the back coming out
uh Shea McCarthy how are you I'm good
I'm done thank you for having me thank
you for being with us
so go go ahead it's all you now
I'm very excited about Danny this
project and ever since I I saw it when
you first I started seeing
advertisements for it and you know as
the chef was saying very impressive
mashallah he hasn't uh
um his first lecture he gave in English
which I did a very good job may Allah
bless him and I apologize I'm just I'm
kind of on the go uh I wasn't able to
set myself up for for that but I'm here
with you guys I had to take part when I
was asked to be part of this program uh
alhamdulillah what he said at the end
which is very interesting I think we
always need to focus on especially
Muslims in America and uh you know
living in the West in general where we
were in the west as Muslims that the
prophet Allah the first thing that he
did
when he came to Medina was established
the Masjid
and establishing the massage it is the
way of the mbf we see Ibrahim and he's
the first Masjid ever established on the
face of the Earth in Mecca when he
established the Kaaba so we see
subhanallah that the uh you know this
this is what a community needs to do
when they come to a country that they
establish their massages but something
very interesting that he mentioned as
well the brother is from Bosnia which
you really need to focus on as Muslims
in the west and they're around the world
in general is what was the Masjid during
the time of the Prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam it was not a place for the five
daily prayers it was actually a play it
was of a more of a community center and
that is exactly what uh brother Eddie
and the brothers are trying to do with
the dean show they're with the dean
Center is they're not just establishing
another place for Muslims to pray but
it's going to be a place for an Outreach
for dawa it's going to be a place for uh
the Muslims to to you know have fun and
enjoy themselves it's going to play be a
place for the the dean show which Allah
Mubarak is one of the most any
beneficial and consistent programs that
we've had any in the in the last you
know 10 or more years where mashallah
brother Eddie may Allah bless him you
know he's keeping it real
bringing the things that the Muslim
ummah needs to hear not just in the west
but around the world as well he's
bringing the things that we need to hear
the things that benefit us you know from
from the dean side to you know medical
issues uh any in-depth any uh podcast
you know with great uh Scholars and and
and preachers and Educators that he has
come with him on the on the show and and
to benefit the ummah alhamdulillah so
this is something that's been consistent
and beneficial it's going to get even
better now have the the platform there
where it's going to be the studio the
professional studio and at the same time
you're going to be able to train some
Jujitsu with brother Eddie and and
that's what the community needs the
community needs places where they can go
they can you know kind of you know wind
back have fun you know take it do some
sports you know work out and then have a
place to pray as well the kids can come
and learn Quran they can learn jujitsu
on the side as well and and then and go
and pray their prayers so this is
exactly what we need alhamdulillah so
this type of Center is is it's what's
missing that we have the the massages
that have been set up but our elders
when they came to our countries there's
one of the first things that they did as
well just like the prophet Islam did is
they set up the massage and this is
something brilliant but now in the days
that we live in
do we actually really need more massage
it
and something even more important than
the massage it and this is any one of
the uh or some of the scholars talked
about this before the importance of any
been at as Sajid
you need to build the the people who are
going to utilize and benefit the massage
it before you you you build the the
Masjid itself and that's that's very
important and this type of Center is
going to help us to be able to do that
to have a place where any it's it's more
of a community center it's a place where
people can have fun they can come there
they can enjoy themselves any having
someone like Eddie who came from
you know ajahillia background and we
know the Hadith the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam and it's not something
obviously we come and brag about our
backgrounds in jahiliyah but if it's
something that can benefit us to benefit
us
that's something you know it's very
helpful we've we've been there we've
done that we've seen it we've been down
that path so now when we we've been
there we can help the youth we can help
the community in order to bring them
inshallah closer to the massage and to
benefit and someone like Eddie he knows
exactly what the community needs and
that's why we need to step up we need
the help and to support this project and
I was I was very happy when I was
invited to be part of this program in
order to encourage the brothers and
sisters inshallah to take part in this
when it comes to the message
he said
that the Masjid is the house of every
believer
and Allah said about the message in
Surat Toba chapter 9 verse 18 in
that the mosque of Allah are only
maintained by those who believe in Allah
in the last day and establish the prayer
and they give the zakat and
Allah that they do not fear except for
Allah and then Allah said at the end of
the verse
[Music]
that perhaps these are the individuals
who be from the rightfully guided
may Allah
the one who has true Iman he is the one
who builds the massage and establishes
massage it and frequency for all
that they will be from the ones whose
heart is attached to the messaging so
building these type of Messiah we have
to realize that this the dean Center is
not just any ordinary you know five
daily prayer Masjid it's much greater
than that but he said you know the
support the sports facility or the youth
are going to come and they're going to
train and they're going to benefit and
that is going to make them closer to the
message where they can have that and
I've seen many many in many examples
like that I'm not as many as we want to
but we've seen the examples that when
you have these type of activities the
youth become attached to the Masjid and
they might go for for the other reasons
as well right they want to go and train
they want to be with their friends but
what happens when the Adan gets called
Bismillah he's in there and there's a
there's something very important for the
parents to know that most of our kids
don't make
pay attention to that and I have my son
he's probably in the kitchen now he's
listening to me we call him Mr old
because he never breaks his Allah he's
always honorable maybe he does I don't
know but the point being is that most
kids we found this this is this his
studies prove this is that kids if
they're honest with you they always say
yeah I got world over but when he goes
to the Masjid we found this some of them
they had these these activities and then
massage it that they you know they see
their their colleagues making wodo right
so they would you know go make Willow
with them and then they start to pray
more and get more more involved in the
prayer they see the importance of the
prayer so when you have this atmosphere
when you have you have a gym you have a
basketball court and then this place has
places outside like for for a football
field as well alhamdulillah so all these
activities are happening there you have
the dean show that's going to be there
the guests are going to be coming uh all
the you know the lessons the Quran
lessons and if you take part in that
whatever you give you're gonna have a
part of the edge of Anyone who reads the
Quran there anyone who learns every Dean
show which is film there and spread out
you're going to take part of the Azure
as well inshallah anyone who comes close
to the team an outreach program for the
tower for the non-muslims anyone who
comes and accepts Islam there you get
part of the reward anyone who learns
about Islam and the misconceptions are
removed from them from the dean Center
also you're going to take a part of that
reward as well so my advice as I end our
brother
um may Allah bless him he's here now
inshallah to step in so as he's about to
step in I would like to encourage all my
brothers and sisters to take part in
shalota in this great opportunity
realize it's like I said it's not just a
regular Masjid this is a unique
opportunity that we all need to step up
and support whatever we can in Shalom is
foreign
you know you nailed it all you gave
every reason out there that people might
be looking for to donate if you believe
it's a
do you believe in dawah it is a dawa
Project donate if you believe that youth
need to have a safe place to grow donate
every reason is out there my beloved so
in the interest of time take the message
that is given by Sheikh to your heart
and allow your heart to do what is right
that is to donate generously and time is
not today inshallah without further Ado
I would like to request the next yes
inshallah to come on and I really wanted
to thank all those guests and heroes
online waiting patiently continue to
make Dua inshallah that may Allah guide
the hearts of the humanity to donate
generously for this noble cause
oh
assalamualaikum for everyone who
um has been waiting
um I've also been waiting because I
wanted to share something with you
I think maybe start anecdotally because
sometimes especially if you're familiar
with my work the way that I usually
articulate an argument is in a very kind
of rigid format logical format and so on
but in the spirit of speaking about this
new dollar Center
and
that Eddie inshallah is going to become
the operational manager of
I wanted to start by saying that really
in the beginning of I'm 30 years old now
uh most people don't believe that
because I look much older you know most
people think I'm in my 50s or 40s or
something like that I'm actually 30
years old
and I I remember when I was growing up
I used to um watch the dean show in fact
I used to watch the dean show in my
formative years when I was maybe 15 16
17.
and it was a substitute of some sorts of
like television series or television
shows or something like that it was an
Islamic substitute
and it was a fantastic it was it was
really amazing because it was the first
time the Muslims had been well at least
on the online space introduced to
something like that in English-speaking
world
and I remember my own formative years
you know watching the dean show and
watching Eddie very consistently
uh you know introduce different guests
from from America from different parts
of the world talking about different
issues
though I would say that this really in
terms of my own development as a Muslim
it was integral
it was actually
integral and this is me in the UK like
you know thousands of miles away on the
online space discovering what what Eddie
done and the Quran and what it talks
about certain Deeds
you know Allah for example in Social
history says
that non-equivalent are the people who
give in the sake of Allah
and strive in his sick those are higher
than those who come after
and obviously the Quran also says
the ones who came before so the idea of
coming before and doing a deed
and you know this is something which is
in The Chronic discourse Eddie from the
dean show he really he was the the SS we
would say the foundation he was the
beginning of the online podcasting space
the interviewing space after that people
started to kind of mimic it uh copy it
but he laid the foundations
and as I say I'm speaking for my own
personal experience in the last 15 years
I've seen him be the most the single
most consistent person online
uh on the online space doing Islamic Dao
and I've seen his own progression as a
host he's never come outside of his Lane
who's been very humble and sincere
always had very very interesting
conversations
and really made an impact in the Muslims
space now just the fact that you have
Eddie probably the most consistent
individual in the online space
being the operational manager for this
particular data center that's enough I
think that's all you need to know about
the situation
because you know the Quran says
I mean the best person to employ
is destroy is the competent person
and it's this trustworthy person
and in terms of online dower the most
competent and consistent individual I
would say in the English-speaking world
is Eddie from the dean there's no one
more consistent than him by
I would say so from this perspective I
mean that's why I wanted to come on and
speak because I thought I owed it to
Eddie I owed it to the dean show I owed
it to the online dower for someone like
Eddie to be able to do that and the fact
that as as mentioned as well that he's
he's also involved in sports people
won't know that Eddie from the dean show
and his brother as well and other people
there are top tier athletes in in Jiu
Jitsu top tier athlete centers you know
in involved in in sports which like
grappling the grappling arts and that's
going to be an integral part of this
particular Data Center there's a book
that was written by ciuti in fact which
is called el masara
which is the hastening to grappling
and I think it has been translated I'm
not sure but it's it's this idea of
grappling as a sport as a martial arts
sport you know it's one of I mean
if anything is Sunnah
with boxing and striking Sports there's
discussion about it but with anything
this is sun and the fact that he's
putting this in there teaching young men
young women young people how to defend
themselves how to I mean it's everything
you need it's and it's everything you uh
want and this is really why I think that
you know this cannot be an opportunity
that we miss I think we will regret this
opportunity this if we miss this
opportunity to to Really to contribute
to that I'm telling you that if it
wasn't for me you know if it wasn't for
any that I probably maybe I wouldn't be
here today be giving dawa maybe that was
the the piece of the puzzle that Allah
he wanted me to see those episodes of
Eddie and the dean show Eddie and uh
Norman Ali Khan and Eddie and Yasser
khaldi and Bilal Phillips and green and
all of those figures even Zakir Nike
amazing episodes maybe Allah needed me
to see that when I was 15 to 16 years
old so that I can become a dire and do
whatever I'm doing today bringing people
to Islam stopping people from leaving
Islam
you see the multiplier effects and maybe
when Eddie comes on the on the day of
judgment he'll see all of the Good Deeds
that I'm getting maybe he'll see a copy
of those as well because of that
but then the question is if a tower
center is created and is there's an
organizational effort what will the
future hold
and then if you put money into this
if you contribute to this
I mean what will you see on the day of
judgment what will you see because
the one who leads to the good is like
the one who does the good
so we have to be brave and courageous
here we're not we cannot be stingy we
cannot be misery because honestly these
are the most for me they're the most
important projects in terms of Saddam
that's why I always advertise for these
kinds of dollar centers and stuff
because I personally believe that it's
the number one priority for Muslims if
you get people who care about
dawah and become generous and they know
the virtues of Islam then they will help
the humanitarian situations
then they will by themselves be so
you're creating a an environment
where people want to give sadakhan other
causes the Dao Center is really the
Asana it is the foundation of everything
it is the thing which will stop people
from becoming apostates our children and
our grandchildren from becoming
apostates it will bring people to the
religion of Islam
it will create a community center so
that people can feel proud of their
religion it will engender at a deep
state of Islamic identity in the
community
what more can you want what what else
can you invest in if not this is an
opportunity
and the fact that investing in something
like this it will
engender a sense of Bravery in your own
heart because it takes a brave person to
give money to give charity and something
they will not see the immediate results
for in the age of immediate
gratification
but what can we say and what can we do
this is this is what we I would rather
feel as if I'm losing something okay
but then create
a virtue from within which is the virtue
of being generous the virtue of being
brave the virtue of being a strong
believer
then I have to wait 20 to 30 years and
then regret it when your children or
your great-grandchildren or whoever it
may be are leaving Islam in droves
so this is an opportunity of life and I
I wanted to start off with the anecdote
and you know subhanallah one of the
great evidences
uh of the fact that Eddie from the dean
shows dawa and his efforts have been
successful is the fact that it has so
much Kabul so much approval and
acceptance
now you may think what's that got to do
with anything there is a Hadith I'll
read it to you in fact
it's a Hadith Muslim
said I'm going to read in English when
Allah loves a Slave he calls jibril and
says I love so and so so love him
and then jibril loves him then he jibril
announces in the heavens saying Allah
loves so and so so love him then the
inhabitants of the heavens I.E the
Angels also love him and then the people
on Earth love him and when Allah hates a
slave he calls jibril and says I hate so
and so so hates him then jibril hates
him he jibril then announces amongst the
inhabitants of the heavens verily Allah
hates on so so you hate him thus they
also start to hate him then he becomes
the object of hatred on the earth also
if you look at the din show and the
acceptance in the Muslim Community it is
the emblem of mainstream acceptability
in terms of suddenly discourse online it
is if you want to know where the middle
ground is if you want to know where the
Warsaw player is if you want to know
whether Kabul and the approval is look
no further than the Deen Show where is
the Hub of all of the mainstream
speakers in the Islamic world today look
no further in the Ninja the fact that it
has this much backing that has had this
much approval that has had this much
acceptance is inshallah I will say
inshallah based on the Hadith we've just
read
an indication of the sincerity of its
Founders and inshallah once again more
evidence to us that this is the kind of
thing you want to invest in because once
again we want the competent people and
the trustworthy ones and you know I will
say one thing else in fact on this in
this regard
McCarthy
[Music]
um
he was mentioning
something in Surah to Toba and there's
something else that came to my mind in
Surah September as well
uh where Allah he cautions the prophet
Muhammad
from praying in the Masjid okay where it
was established by the moon
okay in fact Allah says
do not ever go to that Masjid
a Masjid that is established upon taqwa
on God Consciousness is better that you
stand in it
the message is called Masjid it was a
Masjid that some of them the Hypocrites
they established it for social and
political game
nowadays when Muslims were investing in
projects and stuff it's not enough okay
what project is it because we can be
investing in any part of the world in
whatever project it may be but it's
about what is the track record of those
individuals who are heading this project
it's it's not good enough to just invest
in a Masjid
or invest in a dollar Center
or invest in whatever even a
humanitarian project we must do a due
diligence check to see if those
who are the
supervisors of that particular operation
are themselves figures of taqwa and
sincerity
and as I say
from what is apparent and that's all we
can say from what is apparent we will
get no better and I tell you this with
all
vociferousness and all vigor
you will not get anything more sincere
than Eddie from the dean show you will
not get something more continuous than
any should not be something more
competent than it so this is I say
with all certainty in my heart and no
uh incentive whatsoever I'm not I can
guarantee you um Eddie has not given me
any uh monetary compensation for this or
um you know I'm saying this because I
mean this uh and I because because I'll
say I feel like I I have a duty of care
to say this kind of thing as a means of
men
whoever does not thank the people does
not thank Allah it's about the personnel
it's about it's about the it's about the
track record it's a it's an opportunity
you don't want it's you cannot it's not
even that you don't want to miss this
opportunity that's putting it lightly
it's actually you can't afford you can't
afford to miss an opportunity like this
think about it how can you afford to
miss an opportunity like this
um
how can you afford to miss an
opportunity like this
I I really I really cannot I cannot
fathom why a Muslim Living in America or
living in the west
yeah thank you so very much where your
encouragement your support you are the
testimony Masha Allah and you are the
product of the dean show encouragement
and the services that has been offered
yes
immensely and thank you very much I see
the beautiful smile of my beloved chick
or rather I should say our beloved
Sheikh who always inspired us may Allah
bless him with the long healthy life I
cannot wait to hear from him inshallah
it's all yours no
foreign
you cannot imagine the great joy and
honor that I feel
um this afternoon to say a few words on
behalf of my good brother Eddie our
beloved and behalf of the dangshore
I have to be honest with you
um for me
I love the masjids the Islamic centers
and if you ask me to go anywhere in the
world to help raise funds for Masjid I
would I would glarly do it
and but I have to be honest with you
but my real love and passion
is to do with hair
in the United States
one-third of the Muslim ummah
live in non-muslim countries
so what do you find them
find them in the United Kingdom you find
them in Germany you find them in France
you found them in Belgium and you find
them in the United States of America
I don't know what percentage of Muslims
are in this country
maybe one percent maybe two percent at
Max
but yet if I were going to invest some
money if I had the money if I was a man
of means
easily if I could afford it I would give
Eddie the seven hundred thousand dollars
that they need to complete uh this
particular project
let me tell you why I am so
touched by the work that Eddie has done
he has a track record he's not a Johnny
come lately he's not somebody you know
trying to find traction
he's been around forever
you know to me it seemed like I'm not
Eddie ain't that old it seemed like he'd
been around at least 100 years that's
the kind of impact that he that he's had
and um I'm gonna say something and I
have to be honest with you
every match should have two doors
if they have a front door by which
people become Muslim
I came to that front door Eddie came to
that front door Imam zage Hamza Yusuf
below Phillips Abdullah came quick we
came to that front door
and we also have a back door by which
Muslims that leave the faith in Islam
um a system Morales I listened to her I
attended the igna conference a couple of
weeks ago in in Baltimore Maryland and
she said something that startled me and
frightened me
um she said that 70 of the new converts
the reverts leave Islam
my immediate response was
how do you know that what's the evidence
what are the facts
and then I asked the question to myself
what percentage of Muslims leave the
fold of Islam
it's the job of the imams the leaders
the Open Wide that front door that's
what Eddie does and close that back door
so that no one will leave the fold of
Islam
the thing that I love about the Muslims
in the west by the way
I am the West
we are the West
I am as West as anyone else in this
particular country
and this matched it to be established in
Florida
will continue to be a great Beacon Light
Of Hope
um for for this country not just for
Muslims but for non-muslims
I want to say something about how
children
and those who will leave the faith of
Islam in me
I cannot even imagine me leaving Islam
this is my 48th year of being a Muslim
once I recognize what Islam was in 1975
under the teachings of Imam Waterside
Mohammed I became Muslim alhamdulillah
and as a result I've fasted for 48 years
never missed the fast
alhamdulillah at the end of this year I
would have made 87 000 salats
alhamdulillah and I cannot imagine not
being Muslim
but some of some some of the Muslims are
leaving the faith of Islam
thanks be like for Eddie and and people
like him and his programs
you know who really uh shined the light
of what it is to be a Muslim in this
country to be proud of being a Muslim
um for those of our youth maybe who's
saying I don't want to be Muslim I want
to be like everybody else
really
you want to be like everybody else
you want to be like the majority
let me tell you about a man who was not
in the majority at all
you know and what the prophet peace and
blessing be upon him said about this
great prophet Ibrahim
only something that Allah would know
so at one point
um Ibrahim Allah had a conversation with
his wife Sarah
Lisa hello
Sarah there is not one believer on the
face of the Earth other than you and me
talking about minority you talk about
South Africa one percent of the Muslims
in South Africa you're talking about
them you talking about one man and one
woman
you know the um
this country they call it the Marines
the model of the of the Marines are the
fuel the Brave the Marines
and when you talk about being in a
minority
or like in episode
the majority of the people don't believe
and you go back 1400 years ago
the best of my ummah is my generation
the generation of the Prophet peace and
blessings be upon them
is my generation and then the generation
that follows it and then the generation
that follows it why I'm saying all of
this
my friend yeah cool South Africa texted
me a few months ago he said Imam Suraj
do everything with a good heart
expecting no reward
I said fine I texted him back
do everything with a good heart
expecting no reward
except from Allah
nowhere in the Quran nowhere in the
Sunnah do you see Allah telling us to do
something without us expecting to get
something in return
you know the Congressional Black Caucus
these are the black legislators you know
they have a model
black people have neither permanent
friends or permanent enemies just
permanent
interests and this is what we learned
from Sharia you know Martin Luther King
Jr said life's most persistent and
Urgent question is what are you doing
for others
I agree with him rebuilding this Masjid
for others yeah I agree with him but I
would like to change Martin Luther
King's uh Speech just a little bit
life's most persistent it's an urgent
question
is what are you doing for yourself
by the service of others where I get
that from when you get that from Imam
Quran
whatever good you spend is for yourself
yes this Masjid maybe I'll never go to
Florida and attend that match it doesn't
matter
but somebody will go there
and knowing Eddie
that hard-working brother knowing him
he's going to have an impact wherever he
go so I'm making the dura Allah will
bless him raise all the money that he
needs and to see this Islamic Center
this message and I'm going to close with
this Sheikh I'm going to say something
that's a little bit controversial
um and people you may you may not like
what I'm going to say yourself but I say
it because I've I've really I've studied
this thing for a long time
and uh you know there's no question
about about sahaba how great they are
uh one in fact one day he's talking to
his companions and the prophet peace and
blessing be upon him said um
uh wood that I can meet my brothers
they said aren't we your brothers you
must have my brothers will come after me
they will believe in me though they have
not seen me
now you know Sheikh I used to be a
Christian and there's a very interesting
uh verse in the Bible where Jesus is
talking to Thomas and he says to Thomas
Thomas because you have seen me you have
believed
but blessed are those who will believe
me and not have seen me so seeing is
something important people say seeing as
believing no no no no no seeing as
affirmation not seeing is believing let
me give you let me give you the proof
Allah asks the angels and whenever Allah
asks a question he don't ask the
question because he don't know the
answer he asks a question to teach a
lesson he asks Angels what are my
servants saying what are they saying
alhamdulillah they're praising you Allah
do they see me no they don't see me
what if they saw me oh they saw you they
really be right and then he's Allah said
but what are they ask him for they're
asking for your Jannah how do they see
it no no what if they saw here you are
doing all of this for gender that you
have never seen what you believe and
what are they seeking Refuge from they
say secret Refuge from the Hellfire how
do they see it no they didn't see the
Hellfire but they believe
so I'm saying I'm gonna say something
this is the controversial statement and
you say I didn't say the mama said he
came on I couldn't stop him he said
let me say first the prophet peace and
blessing be upon Him is comparing us to
his companions
he said
don't you ever insult my companions
for if you spent
gold
the signs of Mount uhud it wouldn't
equal a handful of what one of them
spent even a half a handful so nobody
can argue how we gonna compete with Abu
Bakr and Uma and all of the rest of our
Companions and this is the this is the
point I'm going to say shape don't get
mad at me you may not invite me again
when you read when you read Hadith
literature right
now
and some Hadith says um
the mother of the faithful why because
Allah says and the wives of the Prophet
are your mothers so she's our mother
um
Abdullah
I used to never had children
why is she called the mother of Abdullah
who is Abdullah
well Abdullah is the son of a sister
asthma
and here it goes this is the point
Abdullah
was the first Muslim born in the Muslim
family
every one of them were Converse or
reverse
every one of them every one of them the
best Uma ever was that generation and so
I'm saying that alhamdulillah because of
people like Eddie and and and by Law's
commission all of these people coming in
the front door coming to the fold of
Islam as Sheikh you and I begin to close
that back door and don't let nobody else
out
so may Allah bless this program to bless
to raise the money we'll raise it and
show a lot we raise it and more and I I
pray Allah continue to bless both Eddie
a good brother really a good Muslim you
shake may Allah blessing in your family
life and allow us to benefit with your
presence inshallah this is for
generations to come inshallah Allah my
dear audience the way that you have
heard every word that came out of Imam
siraj came directly from his heart
and he has urged many Muslims to raise
millions of dollars now Allah has
blessed us to have Sheikh encourage all
of you to donate for this dawa Center
this is it my brothers and sisters do
whatever you can to support and take
part in this project and this is the new
hijri year 1444.
start your new year by donating in this
new project insha Allah this will become
the legacy of Muslims here in America
so we're gonna try something new here
because of time constraints we're going
to bring all of our guests on together
so uh we're going to do it the dean show
style will ask Eddie to join as well and
we'll get the brothers on together
inshallah we have brother also from
International Community as well
um
how are you all doing how my brother's
doing we got all the
all the brothers joining in how's
everybody
we got an All-Star lineup alhamdulillah
sorry to keep some of you waiting in the
back we had some people go over their
time
so let's go ahead and let's take it take
it away
who was lined up next we had everybody's
here yeah we got the most beautiful
smiles mashallah I'm looking forward to
hearing every one of you I'm very
excited to see you all
right we're even more excited nah
mashallah
so we got Imam Wesley in the house from
the right to the left we got uh we got
our brother from Bosnia Faith how are
you doing
how you doing
I'm doing good alhamdulillah how are you
we got uh Sheikh Mustafa
and we got and we got Kuwait in the
house that's right
foreign masha'allah
he's been watching 84 years now he said
and he is very famous in our country
[Music]
so go ahead uh we were going to have
everybody speak for 10 minutes we're
going to kind of cut it down because we
kind of many of the previous speakers
someone over the time so we didn't want
to keep many of you also have a schedule
Mustafa you gotta you have another
appointment also so let's start uh let's
go with the Fati uh you were lined up
next uh let's go ahead and take it with
you and then we'll go with uh uh
everybody else who just come on in and
we're cut the topics Muslims in America
we talk about the importance of dawah
you know and people know what we're
trying to do with the D Center and
everybody here is involved in conveying
this beautiful message sharing the
purpose of life with the people they
know you know the value of it you know
trying to remove the many misconceptions
uh all of you most of you've been guests
on the program
uh and I've seen the Young Brother here
also to see if you know Fati from uh I
remember when we met uh you came out in
Texas you were how old were you like 12.
a long time long time ago
yeah
um
for having me here and like you said
um it seems like ages ago when I was in
Texas I was very young and you were
still doing amazing work even back then
and until now you've continued your
amazing work and I've been following you
uh over the years and myself I've
benefited from you a lot and um uh what
I really wanted to come and say here
today because I do watch a lot of your
podcasts with your guests and um one
that really stuck with me subhanallah
like you know this this one moment and
one of your podcasts that you had
recently that really stuck with me uh it
was uh with one of the convert Brothers
I think he was from Mexico or from the
cartel and he was talking about his uh
journey to Islam and how he became
Muslim
and one thing that really really stuck
with me that I think about all the time
is when he was talking about when he was
in his darkest moment when he was
struggling and uh he wanted to call upon
Allah and ask Allah for help uh he was
suicidal I believe he mentioned that he
failed a suicide attempt and he was just
sitting in the room miserable and he
didn't know what to do and what he
mentioned was the fact that he just
looked up in the sky he looked up in the
sky and he said you know you know
whoever you are you know whatever you
are up there if you're there you know
please help me
um and that really made me appreciate us
as Muslims one of the things that we
don't really appreciate and we take for
granted I feel like most Muslims we take
for granted is the fact that at the bare
minimum alhamdulillah we know
Allah's name we know God's name and we
know how to call upon God and when we
call upon him we know how to pray to him
even if we're not the most practicing
the most religious you know at the bare
minimum somebody that's been born Muslim
that has a relationship with Allah at
any level has the ability to call upon
Allah and have that comfort and
confidence to know Allah by his name and
call upon him and pray to him in a way
that's befitting and that Allah is
pleased with and that brings so much
comfort to our hearts and our souls
because when we're going through that
difficult time first of all we know that
Allah is there alhamdulillah is a Muslim
even when I struggled and went through
some of my hardest times I never when I
prayed to Allah I never had to say oh
Allah if you're there you know I I
always said with full confidence in my
heart you know Allah I know you're there
and uh please please help me and just
even knowing Allah's name is a huge
thing because it makes it like a
personal relationship you know like for
example you Eddie I know you if I come
up to you and I say
you know brother Eddie I need some help
you know can you help me I feel a lot
more comfortable because I have that
relationship with you I know your name
then if I went to some random stranger
you know on the street and said hey
personal if you're there but you know
he's there you could see the person on
the street but if you go up the Ranger
and someone you don't know and you're
like Hey sir can you help me you don't
have that same confidence and
reassurance as you do when you actually
are able to call somebody upon their
name because that indicates that you
have some kind of relationship with them
so even though that was maybe a small
thing in that podcast because mashallah
that brother he talked about a lot of
things but it really made me appreciate
you know looking back at my own life
that we take it for granted the fact
that we have a relationship with Allah
subhanahu Thailand that we can call upon
him so it is amazing work that you're
doing and this institution obviously uh
you know is a source for dawa and many
people inshallah through this uh
institution in this Masjid and that was
Center will come to Islam and um you
know the only thing I just want to add
to this I don't want to take up too much
time is as Muslims we have a concept in
Islam where we rely upon Allah
will we rely upon Allah so a lot of
Muslims they rely upon Allah
but some people they practice something
that's called tawakul which is another
Arabic word which means relying upon
Allah but not putting in the work so
basically you just sit at home and you
expect Allah to take care of you and to
feed you and to give you you know money
or whatever it is right that's tawakul
in Arabic but is where you rely upon
Allah and you don't sit at home you
actually put in the word you get up
every day you do your best you try your
best and Allah provides for you so we as
Muslims in America we have this Reliance
upon Allah that he's going to take care
of us that he's going to preserve the
Deen in in the United States in the west
so he's going to take care of our
children that our children are going to
grow up and be good Muslims okay but a
lot of us we just seem to think that
we'll rely
and that everything will take care of
itself but to what could it asks of us
that we actually put in some effort and
we actually do something to make sure
that Allah will help us and some of the
things that we can do to ensure that
Islam spreads in the United States and
that our children are able to grow up as
practicing Muslims is building centers
like these and putting the effort to
make centers like these and supporting
causes that help establish and spread
Islam uh wherever it is especially in
the United States so I call upon my
brothers and sisters to support however
they can whatever you can do it's gonna
obviously contribute a lot and it's
going to benefit a lot and maybe it
won't benefit you but it will benefit
the Next Generation and it will benefit
the youth and insha Allah through your
efforts and your donations many people
will enter Islam and like brother imman
just saying before us they will stay in
Islam and they will make the changes
needed not just in the United States or
in the west but Islam is a change that
we need for the whole world right now
and inshaallah
wherever it begins whether it's here
whether it's you know it will continue
inshallah and spread around the world
and improve the lives of many many
people for having me uh I just ask all
of you guys to kindly donate to uh to
this cause may Allah bless you and Lord
all of you
once again thank you so very much you
heard it Brothers do what you can to
support this noble cause inshallah I
have a next speaker inshallah next in
line to speak he has other program also
you need to Pat catch up with inshallah
is that the first thing is uh you know
the effort of dawa it's really important
that some people have a personality uh
more extroverted a more uh you know a
brave and courageous personality when
they're conveying The Message of Islam I
think every Muslim or most Muslims have
in their heart the desire to spread the
message of Islam you know Muslims love
their religion they believe it's the
truth and they want to share that truth
with other people but not everyone has
the the personality or the wording or
the style of presenting the message in
the in the best of ways or even has the
courage to present the message to get a
little bit timid alhamdulillah one of
the greatest things that I've noticed
about the dean show is is Eddie and the
other people that he brings on the show
they're able to convey The Message of
Islam in a way that's people can
understand a way that people can relate
to alhamdulillah I've seen Eddie's in
his interviews uh with people come in
and just deliver the message of Islam in
the way that is supposed to be delivered
and not everyone can do that but you
Deport people who have experience
who have
perfect at this but who have more
experience who are specialized in this
so this is the first point I want to
make I think this is a great cause
because we got the right people who are
backing it who are behind
number two is that the prophet
sallallahu said that authentic Hadith
he said that the people who are extreme
uh will be destroyed so Islam is really
about balance and when we talk about
conveying The Message of Islam through
dawah we also have to realize that it's
very important to present a good
balanced perspective and picture of
Islam when people come into the religion
you know they also need to be cultivated
into the religion so you know people
who've been in the dawah scene people
who've been you know taking Islamic
classes you know sometimes they start
out on this side of the extreme or that
side of the extreme eventually if they
keep learning they keep interacting with
other people they start to kind of
balance themselves out and realize that
we got to be inclusive of all you know
different types of scholarship I've seen
that messaging with Eddie I've seen that
messaging with the dean show I've seen
the variety of speakers that they they
bring on of course always within the
boundaries of Allah
but uh they bring in different
perspectives they bring in different
styles and that's something very
important for one bringing you know
conveying The Message of Islam and also
keeping people you know in the fold of
Islam nurturing their Islam so
alhamdulillah definitely encourage
everyone to support this Center support
this great effort may Allah put Baraka
in it may Allah bless it and bless each
and every single one of you
thank you so very much once again you
spoke very clearly and every word that
you said resonated with all of us now
here I have the Beloved Imam inshallah
waiting Allah
brothers and sisters we are in this uh
beautiful sacred month not only is this
the new year
this is also a stamp for us a mark for
us regarding the migration of the
Prophet sallallahu from Mecca to Medina
not only that but this is also a stamp
and a mark for us showing the love the
commitment the dedication and the
submission that the prophet sallam and
his companions did when they migrated to
Allah
right and this migration
we're talking about this time period it
consists of that love for Allah
right not knowing when we were going to
reach Mecca what they were going to have
but they knew that because they left
everything behind it would have loved a
lot of time right
this is what this project is all about
this project is about spreading the love
of Allah getting people to love Allah to
them embracing Islam and then finding
the level of Allah and I can remember
masha'allah I've known Eddie for maybe
over a decade the first time I was on
the show was probably a
a brother who's sincere a brother who
mashallah is hard working a brother who
really cares about the Deen subhanallah
right and this Dean Center is something
that is way overdue here in America
right we should have had Dean centers
right forget it Dean Center we should
have had Dean centers by now and this is
why we need to support Eddie in this
cause inshallah right as the brother
mentioned right subhanallah the reward
he says it may not benefit you but I
just disagree door you are going to be
one of the biggest recipients of this
inshallah if money feeds to be led to
establish this sensor on the face of the
Earth for the sake of Allah the prophet
salallahu said
the one who guides someone to good is
like the one who does good every time
someone makes sajida in that place you
get the reward every time the doors open
they shout out for Salah for juman for
activities for whatever it is for every
is going to be great on
es because maybe once you had that but
once behind it
amazing
through this
and this is by Allah says
there should always be a group for among
you inviting and calling that is
in the time and error in which we are
living
with so many difficult situations
brother Eddie is dealing with those
talking about him talking about them
they lost by the wayside and Allah says
when we do all of these things when
there is that group of individuals who
have invested in a project like this so
that we can call to the good forbid the
wrong he says that they are the ones
because with Allah
why because this is a complete
investment for Creative Roi forget about
your 401k forget about all that forget
about your residual income that you've
invested in this the best original
income is with Allah
already seen the proof in front of us
[Music]
to keep them sincere keep usability and
to keep him busy doing the work that
needs to be done that many individuals
don't have the time for and how many
people were going to put the time the
effort the love and the dedication into
it so that inshallah those of us who may
not have the opportunity can do it
through so I say donate invest you're
going to find it with Allah and there's
never going to be any loss with Allah
show the same love that the companions
had when they gave up what they love
meaning your wealth give it up to date
and if you do that you're tomorrow yeah
is going to be much better we love you
brother Eddie inshallah continue to
increase you
foreign
but I have seen a great concern overseas
for this kind of work very passionate
individuals and institutions out there
who are longing for opportunity to give
generously and ready to offer their
advice in this regard and through this
kind of work we are reaching out to
those individuals such as in Kuwait
other UAE KSA other Muslim countries
over there who are very passionate and
very appreciative of the work Muslim
Americans are doing in dawa what is that
what is doing is literally painting the
picture and telling the story that the
way Muslim ought to be telling this
story the world needs to know the true
reality of Islam Muslims there is about
time that Muslims take charge of telling
their stories the way it's supposed to
be and any for decades has been doing
this job single-handedly through the
help of being sure now is the time to
have a team Center where that work can
be multiplied many poles inshallah with
that I would like to invite our brother
from Kuwait to say few words inshallah
who's been following for years now
for giving me an opportunity to speak
with you so Dean show I've been watching
it for quite for some time and as you
all know the insha is washed across the
globe and they are doing a wonderful job
especially brother sister brothers and
sisters we need to keep in our mind one
important thing you know uh when it
comes to whatever Good Deeds that we do
we do for the sake of Allah expecting
reward from Allah two of the activities
that are going to fetches lot of reward
immense reward are going to be combined
that is building of Masjid and adava
Center together so imagine what kind of
immense reward it's going to fetch you
it's going to bring it to you so my dear
brothers and sisters this is going to
serve as a continuous charity for you
throughout your life and even when you
have left this you know done here and it
is going to benefit us not only us but
it is this the center is going to serve
for the next decades to come for Muslim
Generations Muslim um insha Allah so
here uh my dear brothers and sister I
would like to you know like
you know bring forward two important
points the one point that brother Eddie
is doing he has been doing is that he he
invites every eminent scholar to the
show and he provides an opportunity to
directly hear from the eminent Scholars
not only eminent Scholars of Islam but
sometimes he brings you know like he
invites non-muslims as well so that we
can get to know the different point of
views or you know the misconceptions
that they have it provides an
opportunity to dispel their
misconceptions this is one of the
important things and the second thing
that this Dean should does is it you
know spreads the correct knowledge of
Islam the true knowledge of Islam
according to the Quran and Sunnah so
this is an activity which everyone has
an obligation to support the third thing
was made to say he was asked to say in
the Quran
it says say that it is my way that you I
invite people to Allah
I invite people to Allah with with
inside with knowledge with evidences I
and my followers
so this verse is a unique verse it's an
important verse that that shows our
responsibility that tells us our
responsibility the way of rasulullah was
calling people to Allah
with evidences what's inside and so is
our way so it should be our way so ought
to be our way
so my dear brothers and sisters no none
of us who has the knowledge of Islam
little knowledge of Islam can neglect
this obligation
so brother Eddie is doing this you know
on a larger scale so it is it becomes
our responsibility to support him this
this has to be you know kept in our mind
says
whosoever invites to goodness he will
have the similar reward you know that of
the reward that of a doer the one who
does he gets what he want the similar
reward is given to the one who invited
him to the goodness so imagine what kind
of immensely what you are going to have
so here I urge all of our all of our
brothers and sisters to expend your
money support him and whatever way you
can contribute contribute to him and you
know many many a times we spend a lot of
money on unnecessary things without
thinking without fearing anything but
when it comes to the Deen and this kind
of activities shaytan puts in our heads
Lord of you know like you know a
different kind of fears because of those
fears we do not you know we hold our
hands do not hold your hands please you
know like open up your hands this this
act whatever you know you you spend here
for this Deen Show and this Masjid insha
Allah insha Allah it will serve as a
means of najat for us inshallah so I
request all of my brothers and sisters
to generously and you know support this
actum Allah
you bring that Spirit off the kuwaitis
you know they are very generous and
passionate about these things and the
generosity and the passion may Allah
continue to bless you Brothers out there
and continue to help you and support you
and motivate you inshallah
thank you so very much foreign
probably the the far end of of our globe
of Australia of the world alhamdulillah
so I'm here in Melbourne and uh you know
mashallah I've just joined in here with
the dean Center thing masha'allah a few
things I just wanted to you know um uh
put together you've heard a lot of
speakers and and uh a lot of uh details
of the upcoming project inshallah three
aspects the first one the Tao of the
prophet the second the Darwin the 21st
century and the involvement of me and
you as individuals in the dawah so the
first The Tao of the prophet salallahu
alaihi and the previous prophets we all
know and we have been hearing this that
the prophet salallahu alaihi and all the
prophets their main job their core
responsibility was to convey the message
of Allah's Deen to the people around
this was their responsibility this was
the job of the prophets so as you can
title it the profession of the prophets
that would be the dawah of the Deen of
Allah
so while the prophet salallahu Islam is
strived for it why all the other
prophets before the prophet salallahu
they all strive for it they set a
benchmark for us that we need to follow
that in their footsteps so we know the
the troubles the trials the tribulations
then the prophet and his companions had
we know that one of the significant
events that one of the brothers just
earlier mentioned that we are now in the
sacred month of Muharram which happens
to be the month of the migration of the
Prophet salallahu Islam from where the
entirety of the setup of Islam started
as the scholars pointed out the
historians pointed out in the past that
it was those fewer steps that our
beloved Prophet took during the Hijra
during the migration from Makkah to
Madina it set precedence for the entire
Muslim Community to come until the day
of judgment so the entire Islam that we
see today was through as few steps that
were taken as Hijra as migration from
Makkah to Madina
now that set up a benchmark for all of
us now coming or moving forward to the
dawah in the 21st century the purpose
the impact
this strategy majority has remained
similar from the time of the prophets of
Allah we are talking about human nature
we are talking about a human involvement
we're talking about the human response
we're talking about the reaction of the
human beings when and as they come in
contact with Islam That Remains the Same
you know somebody told me a few months
ago when we were having a discussion on
the street Tower with with Australians
here
um and and someone asked the question
that have we not changed have we not
evolved centuries ago from the time of
the Prophet so should not the laws
change in our time
well
on one hand yes technologically we did
progress we did evolve we did change so
all of that requires some sort of
upgradation you know my iPhone that
needs upgradation I don't know if you
guys use iPhone anymore but we all have
different gadgets that we use the
laptops that we use the computers that
we use the the technology does change
the cars that we use you know from from
uh you know fuel based cars from diesel
cars from Petrol cars we've come forward
now to to electric cars and to solar
cars and all of those you know evolving
of Technology yes we acknowledge that
but what we're talking about is the
human nature our emotions if you slap me
I still feel the pain if I hit you you
will feel the pain exactly as a human
would feel 14 centuries or
20 centuries or 30 centuries ago the
human nature seems to be exactly the
same we still have two eyes we have it
evolved to three
we still have two feet we haven't
evolved to three we still have two ears
we haven't evolved to two to three we
still have one time right it hasn't
splitted into two so all of these human
characteristics do remain exactly the
same we still have relationships we
still have you know we cry when somebody
passes away we we feel hurt when it
bleeds we we feel happy when something
good happens all of these human
characteristics remain the same so the
so the nature of the religion so the
laws of the religion concerning the
human nature Remains the Same yes you
will see the fatawa changing about how
to use the phone how to respond on
social media can men and women talk
about each other free mixing whatever it
is the technological fatah will evolve
as well however the rulings for the
human character would remain the same
you still cannot tell a lie you still
cannot harm people you still cannot
humiliate people all of the halals and
Haram remain the same you know if
alcohol was prohibited 14 centuries ever
would remain prohibited now so all of
this gives us an understanding that the
taoistine from the time of the Prophet
to The Tao in the 21st century would
remain the same based on the human
characteristics however the strategies
may change depending on the technology
demanding depending on the access of the
people so now that that one 21st century
we see a lot of different strategies
being used by the emergency Scholars and
the people right now one of that is one
of that is our centers one of that is
having live shows such as the dean show
subhanallah here in Australia
people love brother Eddie's the dean
show and I have to tell you even the
little song that comes right in the talk
the the dean show my kids love it you
know when they watch it here from Down
Under from Australia we all love it you
know here in Melbourne Sydney wherever
you go people know the theme show this
is one of the most popular online shows
for the longest period of time that we
have been knowing it for so these are
different strategies of giving dawa to
the people in our time the Tawas theme
Remains the Same now the Tao in the 21st
century has its own challenges we got
people asking questions against Islam
we've got people questioning the very
essence of Islam we got people
questioning different aspects of Islam
people asking is Sharia fit for for our
time people asking this from the
questions from the seed of the Prophet
all of these aspects are being tackled
and responded accordingly now what is
required is the establishment from the
migration of the Prophet when the
prophet migrated from Makkah to Madina
what was the first thing he said up he
set up a Masjid a place of gathering a
platform
for the spread of Islam whether it is a
Masjid whether it is a tower center
whether it is a show a live show whether
it is a YouTube channel whatever it is
all of these are different strategies
and platforms for the dawah to spread
that is where the Deen Center comes or
kicks into the picture now as I said I
would like to talk about three aspects
the Tower of the Prophet we know how the
prophets how they were engaged in it how
they're involved in it and now comes to
the Tao in the 21st century we've got so
many imams scholars Dua giving dawa
across the globe including our dear
brother Eddie and now comes the third
aspect mind your role in that big tower
scene what can I do what can you do this
is where it comes we need to talk about
the action now I remember sitting and
watching some of the dean show you know
um sessions and and being very happy
about it great amazing but none of those
shows would be of benefit if we don't
put that into action the whole idea
people talk the whole idea is given the
whole idea election is given is so that
people can benefit and bring about in
their actions a change in their actions
this is what is expected now the deal
Center is giving all of us that
opportunity me as an individual can be
part and parcel of the Tao you know
maybe I can't get time all the time to
be on the street I can't be I can't
become a khatib all the time I want to
but I might not be able to do everything
I want to do for the sake of Islam now
remember everything is worked as a team
remember at the time of the prophet
salallahu
everybody chipped in together to achieve
what we see the prophet and his
companions achieved altogether so the
conclusion I would come towards is
from the Ayah of the Quran
where Allah says number six
number 162 and 163 All In
reminds us and tells us say
that my prayers my sacrifice my living
and my dying is all for the sake of
Allah these are all for Allah that is
how our lives should be so my skills my
abilities everything should be
contributed towards the dean of Allah so
my action plan now what can I do now
while the dean Center is coming up what
can I do as an individual to be part of
the Tower of the Prophet all the way
down to the tower in the 21st century I
have got an opportunity today now I
might not build the street dawah every
moment even if I'm doing it an hour or
two I'm not 24 7. I'm not going to be
able to be a khatib for all the time I'm
not going to be a big public speaker for
all the time but today I've got the
opportunity what my chance is
as an individual I can contribute today
to other Center that would make me
involved in every single thing that is
being done people ask me how do we get
the reward by donating to some a center
like this well try and understand every
single speaker that is going to give
he's going to give a talk there every
single Muslim and non-muslim that is
going to visit that place and learn
anything you got to understand you have
a share of reward in that imagine
somebody who never prayed came to the
center and started praying all his
prayers or her prayers throughout their
lives you gotta share in that
you've got to share in that a person who
becomes Muslim through that imagine
imagine this reward a person becomes
Muslim through the center that person
his his partner spouse children
Generations all their progeny you have
earned share in that reward so it is my
and your responsibility my dear brothers
and sisters now every time I used to
watch these show every time I've been on
it I used to think how can I contribute
subhanallah today we got the opportunity
now it can all come to you so let us
contribute for the sake of Allah and
make this Center one of the most Lively
centers one of the most active centers
and let us be the most important part
let's be selfish here let's be selfish
yes the big Dean Center is going to be
there what am I what am I going to get
out of that right
I have an opportunity I put a dollar
there I will have a share of everything
that is going to happen in action on
that center for the rest of my life and
up until the day of judgment Insurance
what everybody is going to contribute
and may Allah give us all equal share
from the entirety of the center and all
the 100 million Americans wake up there
are over 300 million Americans that
don't know what Islam is this is why we
are opening the dean Center the first of
its kind 35
000 square foot Tower Center and Masjid
to show America the Beautiful Message of
Islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch Nationwide Dao programs a
state-of-the-art Production Studio for
online content and an on-site dawa
Center to show what true Islam is donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
[Music]
was him powerful powerful points you
always talk about in a way that really
relates to the audience all those three
stages with the action plan you spoke
very well may Allah deep all of us topic
to utilize this inshallah and along all
the things that you have mentioned that
where donors will have their share
donors will also have the share for
every single reach that Eddie will have
through the dean Center and the dean
show as well it is their golden
opportunity to be part and parcel of
this successful dawa opportunity that
Allah has presented to all of us and
it's not gonna last long
time is now to take part in it and
before you know it inshallah
Deen Center will be a reality so my
beloved there's no movement and
participate inshallah with your generous
donations
we welcome you inshallah please help us
inshallah Enlighten from your wisdom
Allah
salaam alaikum
I did not know if I was up next or how
things were panning out okay
okay
for doing uh what you're doing and for
everybody contributing and doing their
part and may Allah reward brother uh
Eddie on The Dean show for uh
considering me to be one of the
panelists and one of the speakers uh
that's very considerate and thoughtful
of them anyways moving that out of the
side
um it's very difficult to try to be
creative and bring something new uh to
the table just so your speakers are not
listening to the same thing over and
over again and so when you come kind of
at the end uh you have to be creative
and come up with something uh different
just so you're not being uh repetitive
and so uh I thought of of bringing
something maybe different to the table
and that is the concept of authenticity
uh in America and authenticity when it
comes to the dawa in general
um unfortunately what I see happen in
time in time again is that we're talking
about the same things over and over and
over again uh when it comes to just
mainstream and that what I mean by that
is that usually when you walk into hotel
when you walk into a speaker we're
talking about somewhat of the same
subjects right and maybe you could
narrow them down to perhaps five or
seven subjects uh prayer being good to
your parents uh the necessity uh of
voting because you're in America
um being good to your neighbor so there
are four or five the mercy of Allah
there's about four or five different
subjects that you're going to hear on
any given day uh and predict that the
khatib is going to talk about that
subject and so what we need I think and
this is where brother Eddie comes in
Allah we need a voice a courageous voice
a voice that is willing to step forward
and not to worry about the blame of the
blamers right and that is to talk about
unsavory topics that people usually
don't want to delve into because the
word of the Whiplash the word of the he
said that she said and I found brother
Eddie Allah
I have found edit to be that refreshing
voice when it comes to mainstream dawa
and what I mean by what I mean by that
and I can give a few and I will uh give
a few favorite examples
what we don't want and I find this to be
a horrendous mistake when it comes to
dawah and that is that some of some of
the dawah in America revolves on it's
predicated on showing other non-muslims
how we as Muslims are no different than
what is out there and I find this to be
an egregious mistake in methodology when
it comes to displaying The Message of
Islam why that is is because we don't
want people going to the grocery store
and looking at our product at Islam like
all the other million products out there
we want the non-muslims to walk by down
the aisle and look at our product and
say hi this is really different what is
this we don't want them walking past
Islam looking at it like because listen
to be very honest and blunt they've done
to Christianity they've done to to
Judaism what they now want to do to
Islam and we have to Fight 2 and now as
Muslims on the dawah in the tower scene
to say no we're not going to allow
anybody to do with those other religions
to do with Islam forgive me what they've
done with those other religions right so
we don't just want to be another product
on the Shelf I find this to be dangerous
and it is not going to it's not [ __ ]
provoking hey we're just another product
on the shelf by me now we want to show
them that we're different and the only
way we can do this is by remaining firm
remain in steadfast and not playing
around and going into that which is
obviously
and to say hey we're going to change
this yeah we're going to water this down
oh we're going to compromise on this I
think it's only good because we're
living in the 21st century we have to
cater to 21st century sensibilities no
and again I want to reiterate this is
where brother Eddie comes in and does I
believe Allah a phenomenal job he
honestly does and now again I'll give a
few proofs for that brother Eddie Aloha
medic has been doing this for going on
two decades right he's as many brothers
and many speakers that went before me uh
will attest he is consistent he is
honest he is motivated he is courageous
he is creative
this is
this is something I think that anyone
who knows Eddie will casually and
conveniently and confidently say that
Eddie is the man for the job here's the
issue some of us we get
overjoyed and again no one is to be
blamed for that we get very very
comfortable and we're anxious and we
want to spend for the sake of Allah
without digging in to see well where's
my knee going I mean I know it's a mess
[ __ ] but let us not forget that the moon
at the time of the Prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam they built a Masjid and
they called it
that was built but guess what it was a
mission that was built to cause strife
and division division amongst the
prophetic Mission alongside the
prophetic Masjid yes it was a mission
but we as Muslims we have to really kind
of dig a little bit deeper when it comes
to us given our hard-earned money we
don't just give it to anybody and say
hey here you go here's my wealth what
kind of Masjid is this is it a liberal
Masjid whatever that means is it a
progressive Masjid whatever that means
right what are these Muslims who call
themselves Muslims what are they
promoting right is it a 21st century
watered-down version of Islam of hey the
only thing about them about Islam is hey
we're Muslims or so I think this is
where uh credibility comes into place
the Adele of the person who's uh behind
this enormous project this is where it
comes into play and this is where Eddie
comes in to play so authenticity is
something that we need more than ever
today we I think are sick and tired of
seeing the same status quo online and
this is where I think it's befitting for
me to give the examples about um uh Dean
Eddie uh about our brother Dean brother
Eddie on The Dean show right it's the
weekend so don't hold me accountable for
for the tongue twists here
um I was scrolling through I was
scrolling on Facebook not so long ago
and I came across a post where it showed
a hijabi not picking on sisters here by
far um but I came up on this post that
uh the dean show shared and it was
basically a hijabi that was very that
was where the garments were a little bit
too tight exposing everything that was
not supposed to be exposed right a woman
only exposes that kind of material for
her husband and so I thought to myself I
said wow you can still Muslim Dua still
do this today so that was a breath of
fresh air guess what sisters need to see
that today because no one is talking to
them about what is the proper hijab no
one not mean and no one absolutely no
one but it's quite controversial just to
say hey this is halal this is Haram
especially when it has to do with
women's issues and this is something
that I I it's rare to come online and
see right I want my daughter if she's
watching the dean show I want her to be
reminded of what the property job is I
want her to be if and if she is wearing
the proper hijab I want someone that
she's going to come across and for that
person to reinforce right and for
someone to uh uh offer her some some
counsel or some courage or some
motivating words to encourage her uh
be firm dear sister with your proper
hijab for verily that's the hijab that
Allah requires of us there are women who
need to hear that or when I came across
another post about a woman's obedience
to her husband I mean let's be Frankin
honest everybody a woman's over
obedience to her husband is an Islamic
concept
irrespective of what men do and how they
abuse it that's one thing but the
concept itself no one can deny it's an
Islamic concept so to see this
refreshing material that nobody wants to
delve into it's refreshing it's to say
hey at least someone is talking about it
right and one last thing is the concept
even of uh masculinity masculinity in
all of its forms today is being shunned
now I know people will argue and say
well no no brother it's just we're
talking about the toxic masculinity okay
masculinity in all of its forms today is
being shunned it is something that is
not embraced that people have a problem
with and when I heard about the whole
concept of grappling and this is these
services are going to be offered there
we have a problem with masculinity today
and the guests I've seen on brother uh
Eddie's show other Duets would probably
probably think twice about bringing them
on why because it's too controversial it
should not be controversial if we're
it's intra-muslim dialogue and it's
Muslims amongst ourselves between
ourselves between one another it should
not be controversial to talk about and
what a man must do in his house to
protect his wife to protect his honor to
protect the honor of his daughters and
so on and so forth so when I see this
kind of content this refreshing material
that other people would probably close
the door in their faces and say I can't
really have you on our show because
you're not following the status quo so
this is what I appreciate about brother
Eddie he's not afraid to ruffle the
feathers on the help he's not afraid to
den he's not dancing around the Tulips
he's not afraid to rock the boat when
the boat needs to be rocked and this is
something that we how can you not admire
that he's truly a breath of uh fresh air
now I'm not sure how many um how many
minutes I have left here but the concept
of masculinity in these messages that a
lot of our young men and young women are
seen out there um reminds me of
and he says a beautiful bait he says
he says that not having something to do
for all empty empty time right
your youthful years
is money right he says these three
things when you have them for a young
person it is literally the vice of all
vices right to accumulate these three
things into one and to find these three
ingredients actively present within a
young man or a young woman it is a
disruptive Vice for that person so what
we're expecting inshallah from brother
Eddie with this uh with this new center
is that he will provide at least a
friendly Muslim friendly environment
where Muslim women can go Muslim men can
go instead of going to the gym instead
of going to these other communities
inshallah this can be somewhat of an
alternative for Muslims uh to go to I
think a healthy environment growing up
being around Muslims I think that's very
very uh important I think that that
that's of utmost importance
however I will end uh by this inshallah
uh to allow and to make room for the
other speakers inshallah and that is
that uh a Hadith of the Prophet Allah
he walked in on his wife
after them slaughtering a sheep so he
asked her he says
what is left from the sheep that we
slaughtered
she says
o messenger of Allah what is left from
that sheep is only the shoulder is the
shoulder now I want you guys first to
kind of compare the shoulder right to
the rest of the body I mean that's a lot
that's literally what three-fourths
maybe we could maybe no one hold me
accountable to the estimate right but
when you look at the shoulder in
comparison with the rest of the body
that's 25 compared to 75 so literally
she gave away right this was the
generosity of the mothers of the
Believers
they gave away 75 and left for
themselves 25. now the prophet Allah he
corrected her understanding of what's
gone versus what's left so he says to
her
[Music]
he corrected her understanding of how to
view things because life is again it's
about perspective it's about how you
look at things right and that's why
there's the uh English adage don't look
at the cup half empty look at it have
full so it's it's a matter of
perspective
everything is left and the only thing
that's gone is the shoulder meaning that
what really counts in the sight of Allah
what's of value what's really of worth
is what we left out and gave charity
what we are going to eat
this is what's gone right so I think
it's a matter of perspective so
encouraging inshallah when I when I see
the chef's face basically this is an
indicator of okay thank you for your
time now we need more time for the other
one so please dig in your pockets and
dig deep for I will be donating myself
inshallah
thank you very much it's a pleasure
having you on the program inshallah we
can have you back again for an episode
to talk about some of these really
important topics that you just uh yes
please please that that would be a wish
to come true we can ruffle some feathers
as you said yeah please please yeah
say something quickly before I leave I
don't know if you can incorporate this
inshallah in your new shows
and that is um keep uh uh let your Iman
glow by watching the dean show
uh let your Iman grow by watching the
dean show say it again hello yes yes
allow your let your Iman grow by
watching the dean I like that I like
that it's yours I'm not charging you
show I'm not charging we'll send you a
check
thank you so much
inshallah when we get uh the keys we're
gonna have to have you also come down to
the center inshallah it will be a
pleasure of Allah Allah is my witness
that that'll be a dream come true
all right so now we are moving along I
want to apologize to everybody who's
been waiting in the back room and we've
had so many we have a traffic jam some
people have gone over the 10 minutes
all of you everybody came out I didn't
get a chance to to thank the master
hijab Sheikh McCarthy and everybody that
came before him and after him and now we
got uh who's this uh this is what this
is one of my best this is my best friend
here Dr sabil Who's going to be a key
part also is going to pay a key role uh
in the dean center after we get the keys
inshallah go ahead take it away Dr Sabio
Ahmed the director of gain peace
it's an honor you know when I heard
about the dean Center and this
fundraiser and the purchase of the
property I was thinking to myself
alhamdulillah it is happening it is
happening in America it is happening for
the world uh this connecting of the
creation with the Creator
you know this is one of the dreams that
many Muslims may have had in the past
they were not able to they aspired to it
alhamdulillah Allah has given
opportunity to our generation
Muslims living in the USA with the
leadership of brother Eddie and and the
whole team that he has may Allah reward
all of them
so this is happening alhamdulillah
you know make it easy for us give us
success uh have uh us the the right
intention which is so important and help
our fellow Americans and people of
humanity they they realize that who is
the creator what is the purpose of life
and uh how to go to paradise
you know whether Eddie last weekend I
was in Canada right now I'm I'm in
Detroit I was in Canada so when I was in
Canada we had a Masjid open house
many people came close to 150 people
came
when these non-muslim brothers and
sisters when they came to the Masjid one
of my very first thought it went to the
about to be uh you know uh hosted the
dean Center
I was thinking that inshallah as soon as
the Deen Center is going to be like a
modified from inside and purchased with
the help of Allah and the support from
all of you I was thinking inshallah
let's have a open house every single
month let's open the doors for our
fellow Americans so they can come they
can taste the beautiful Message of Islam
so they can inshallah realize the truth
of Islam so one of the ladies or one
couple who came up there and they said
that they live like across the Masjid
and they pass by the Masjid for the last
like you know 25 or so years
they never got the opportunity to come
in the Masjid because no one invited
them the merger did not had an open
house before so this was the very first
time the Masjid had the open house
so I was thinking to myself you know
perhaps there are so many other
non-muslim brothers and sisters all over
all over the USA all over the world they
may be living around the Masjid they may
be living you know down the Masjid but
they never got the opportunity to be in
the Masjid to meet the Muslims and to
learn about Islam so one of the
important missions of the dean Center is
to make sure that we invite our fellow
Americans
so they can come inside the Masjid they
can see the peaceful environment of the
Masjid and of these of This Dean Center
inshallah so their misconceptions they
will go away and they will feel that
Islam is not a threat but it is a
blessing for them and for all of
humanity
so that would be one of the missions or
one of the objectives
of the dean Center one of the three
object objectives I would say is to
share Islam with our fellow Americans to
having a state of the art studio a state
of the art Masjid to have a state of the
art uh new Muslim mentorship program you
know when I was young when brother Eddie
we all we both used to go to
a center which was next to the MCC
Masjid I used to watch the scholar and
non-muslims are used to drop in they
used to come in as they were passing by
and it says Islamic reading room
and people used to come there sometimes
by groups sometimes individually and me
and brother Eddie and other you know
young people of that time we learned a
lot we got empowered from it
so this is this Dean Center inshallah
the second objective besides sharing
Islam with our fellow Americans it is
going to empower our own Muslims how to
break the eyes how to start a dawa
conversation how to explain Islam how to
respond to the uh to the questions
people may have about Islam so the
second objective of the dawa Center is
to train the youth and the adults and
the women and all the Muslims how to
share the beautiful Message of Islam
with our fellow Americans
the third and the most important or one
of the most important I would say
is that all the thousands of people with
Allah's guidance for converting to Islam
or rewarding to Islam as we say they
would be a resource Library like a
resource center one of the dedicated
spaces in the dean Center inshallah so
they can come in they can be connected
with the Muslims they can become
empowered and inshallah they will they
will be integrated in an organic way
so for any and all of these reasons I
would say that Dean Center of this
nature is a really important concept
it's a it's a dream of many many
scholars of the past it's a dream of
many scholars of the current times it's
a dream of Scholars of many many
countries so this will be the very first
center dedicated solely to share The
Message of Islam purely there's the main
focus that's the main mission of the of
of the dean Center is to make sure that
we connect the creation with the Creator
so what I would say whether it is not
just one Dean Center in in Florida right
not just one Dean Center there should be
the incentives in every single major
city in the USA starting with Chicago
perhaps right with Jersey in New York
and la and Houston and Dallas and
Detroit and many many cities
so once we perfect the model in one
place inshallah very soon with the help
of Allah with the support from all of
you just imagine there are 50 Dean
centers in the USA
all of them they open the doors for
people to come in and to learn about
Islam they will have a state of the art
in a studio they would be vibrant and
dynamic programs for new Muslims and
born and raised Muslims and non-muslims
imagine how far and how fast inshallah
with the help of Allah Islam is going to
be spread in the USA
so not just in the USA brother Eddie and
Imam Musa just imagine the incentives
like this all over Canada you know just
last week I was in Canada
just imagine the in centers like this
all over the Caribbean island even in
Mexico Central America South America all
over Europe and Australia martial light
was so nice to see brother Wasim and the
rest of uh the wonderful Scholars
so imagine Dean centers in this concept
all over the world you know we say that
Islam is spreading the fastest in the
world just imagine the incentives all
over the world how fast Islam can spread
and it's not just how fast or slow Islam
is spreading our job as Muslims
is to make sure that first and foremost
we do dawa individually
secondly we should be doing dawa
collectively and thirdly we should be
also supporting those individuals and
those organizations and those centers
and massages who are also Sharing The
Message of Islam
so again I hope and pray that every
single one of us who is watching who is
listening either now or in the future I
hope and pray that you do contribute but
ten thousand dollars fifty thousand
dollars two hundred thousand dollars
right even twenty dollars even ten
dollars and it will also help us if you
can do recurring donation also just
imagine right you may not be here your
family your parents may not be here but
the Perpetual reward be coming back to
you inshallah as brother was in
beautifully mentioned
every person who is going to come and
pray there every youth who is going to
be empowered with The Message of Islam
every new Muslim who is going to be
integrated every non-muslim who would be
educated the reward will be coming back
to you so may Allah help us not only to
purchase the property but to renovate
the property and really soon inshallah
to have active Dynamic Dean Center and
with that we hope and pray that may
Allah accept it from all of us so we can
get the best in this world and inshallah
in the Hereafter ameen Dr Seville thank
you very much
for them very encouraging inspiring
words really thank you so much I want to
introduce uh you Dr Bill to our next
guest sheikhima Musa has met him we've
known him now for over uh I believe 10
years he'll correct me if I'm wrong he
also saw the vision and he put a plan
together and kind of uh you know uh is
helping to get us to this next level
Shaquille how long has it been has it
been 10 years
probably 10 plus yeah ten plus so let's
uh welcome uh Shay Shaquille how are you
good how's it going
okay
seeing you I was looking forward to
seeing you
yeah same here it was great meeting you
here in Florida it's like a friend Dr
Sevilla design for the beautiful talk
good to see you brother so we're gonna
go ahead let uh Sheikh Shaquille take it
away from here and talk about the vision
and talk about the the up and coming
generations and all the other needs that
we're going to be working on in the dean
center with uh Sheikh Shaquille go ahead
take it away
yeah I think the Next Generation uh is a
crucial topic here in the United States
of America
I think one of the things uh that we see
directly
um in our centers
is that the Next Generation needs to
feel a sense of belonging to our centers
so that means strength strengthening our
infrastructure you can imagine today
with all that they see on Tick Tock and
the bombardment of misinformation online
we're seeing a lot of the youth are you
know having questions from atheism all
the way to what their gender should be
and so
um the sense of belonging I think is an
important part of our youth in America
what does it mean to be American and
Muslim at the same time so they are uh
people who feel like you can not be
American and Muslim at the same time
that you have to be one or the other
but I think by having uh this sense of
belonging in our centers
where an American Muslim can walk in and
feel like
that they have not you know landed in a
foreign country you know uh when I was
growing up here in the United States I
remember going to some of the centers
and I felt like I left America for a
moment just for that you know it felt
like when I walked in the center I felt
like I wasn't in America anymore
and that was it was there was there was
culture Clash it was challenging
and that continues to happen today
um and so I think one of the things
that's
challenging today is that our centers
need to have this sense of belonging and
I feel one of the most important things
to Foster this sense of belonging is to
actually uh
deal with the misinformation that's
being spread about Islam online in the
schools
um
there are so many challenges that need
to be met in this regard and so we can't
expect our youth to have to feel a sense
of belonging with our centers uh where
they can proudly be American Muslim when
there's so much confusion about their
identity about Islam itself
so I think like we look back in the time
of the Prophet Muhammad
um while the polytheists were spreading
misinformation depart from Muhammad
sallam had dedicated people there were
people like Hassan
right who would respond to the
misinformation with poetries the prophet
saws this was the prophet's dedicated
poet to respond to islamophobia at that
time and poetry at that time was the
media at that time and so while there
are many efforts that mail the reward
all the brothers and sisters who are
doing great efforts to to to spread the
proper information and the proper
definition of Islam I feel just as the
prophet saw Allah Islam had dedicated
committed people for this cause I feel
like there needs to be a center that is
dedicated that deals with islamophobia
um and honestly the dean show is the
platform
um of for the media there's already uh
efforts being done in this Regard in the
media and so the dean show you know
upgrading itself to be the dean Center
using the media of our time the social
media online platforms to correct and to
clarify what Islam is
it's also important to clarify what
Islam is not right so this is what the
the the the poet of the Prophet Muhammad
would do to tell people what Islam is
and what Islam is not so it's also
important not just to tell people you
know who we worship what Islam is but
also to negate all the false
misconceptions about Islam and that
sometimes I feel at certain situations
can be more powerful and that's why we
have the shahada beginning with what
Islam is not right then so it tells us
what Islam is not and so by
understanding what Islam is not we also
understand what Islam is
um and so I think
this dedicated committed effort where
one body in the United States of America
focuses only just on this because it's
difficult for uh Islamic Center
to do that to deal with islamophobia to
have classes to you know teach to see or
to do Quantum memorization is just is is
difficult to do all of that
at a high scale and so I think we need
to enter a stage of specialization where
we strengthen our infrastructure in our
communities and I think the dean Center
uh is needed there there are we have in
schools where children are being you
know subtly
taught that violence is associated with
Islam so there needs to be a dedicated
organization that goes and questions the
curriculums of these schools throughout
the United States of America right I
must did or average Islamic Center may
not be able to take on that task but if
we have let's say the dean center that
is focused on you know going and
speaking to the people uh in the schools
in public schools where Muslim kids are
going where Anonymous and kids are going
and being taught in subtle ways of how
Islam is violent and Etc that that
curriculum uh the books that they choose
to use to read if they could be an
impact or they can be a workshop that
that can be set up in the schools
throughout the United States of America
where you have a seminar to the kids
about what Islam true is and let them
directly ask Muslims instead of you
having you know a a non-muslim trying to
represent or tell the kids what Islam is
so I think that kind of dedication we're
at that stage in the United States
States of America where we need these
dedicated organizations like we have
care that's dedicated for civil rights
right uh and so I think it's now High
time for us to have a dedicated
organization that will deal with the
misinformation uh that's out there
and I think Dean Center is primed to be
that organization and honestly speaking
uh you know the dean Center will be a
relief you know I'm saying for me
personally because I feel and I and I'm
sure every Muslim does feel every time
we see you know a a
misinformation online or we see you know
a movie where Islam is being represented
in a bad way we feel this responsibility
that it has to be clarified and many of
us may not have that platform that media
platform to reach thousands of people uh
or millions of people as the dean show
does and so for me personally you know
the dean Center the work that it will do
I will feel a lot of relief and a a
lifting of this responsibility that
someone alhamdulillah is actually you
know institution is actually taking care
of this important task
that I believe all us Muslims are
responsible for so I think the least we
can do is is support and build this Dean
Center
um and and and make it a reality so that
hopefully in the day of judgment we
won't be held accountable for the
misinformation and the lack of action
um
or not enough action uh on our part so
may Allah you know bless your efforts uh
uh brother Eddie and all your team
members you know Musa uh Dr Sabio and
the whole team that you have uh to bring
about this amazing organization that
will inshallah be uh stand uh and
clarify what Islam truly is to the
masses I mean I mean
so yes definitely this is uh this is the
team here and we are working hard to
make this a reality and we have uh Dr
Bill so you've met the mamusa but have
you ever met Dr sabil uh Shaquille he's
the director of game piece he'll be
working on the he'll be also a key
component here
I have not met you but just listening to
you I'm like really drawn by the
powerful words that you have said
yes
it is a son of Mary
okay yes
thank you so very much the very
inspiration word and uh Eddie
congratulations to you for putting
together such a wonderful job and work
and inviting Scholars from across the
globe we have audience watching from
entire Middle East India Pakistan and as
far as mashallah Sheikh Wasim was there
from Australia so before the work is
being done and I'm really really happy
and glad that we are putting this
together and the way that Dr sabil and
Shakil has suggested and said that it is
a need of our time it's about time that
we really look into investing in Dean
centers Across the Nation and possibly
inshallah across the globe
and with the hijri that's marked as the
establishment of Madina munawara Muslims
now need to think the same way that it
is about time they struggle times of
ours should come to an end we should
establish
and establish through the establishment
of being sent to us across the globe
inshallah where we can reach out
humanity and address the misconception
that the world has he'll put it really
beautifully he said
it starts telling people what is Islam
is not and that's what the need of our
time people really need to know that and
I love the encouragement Dr sabir and
others have offered Sheikh Imam and
others that invest
with the intention for you to benefit
and also on behalf of those who passed
away of your loved ones
and what better way to do this you know
one thing that always stands out
especially when I visited the site in
Florida Tampa Florida
and it is full of Noor you could see the
reality over there and people walking
into this Masjid it's right on the
street and it is a visibility is very
clear many cars pass through the streets
it's not hidden somewhere in the jungle
rather it's right there out there a
bulletin billboard can also convey the
message like we want to offer open house
open Masjid that will invite many people
just passing by they will see that and
it is an opportunity for many out there
who've been long wanting to give the
message to the Americans and to the
others now you can do it by generously
donating this and converting this church
into Masjid this idea did not even come
from anybody else it's a pastor of the
church himself who had the choice of
selling this property to some other
business owners he said no no no no
I want this to be sold to a place where
it will remain a house of worship from
the same building that he was telling
people to worship Jesus the son of God
he know brother Eddie will
contradict and you'll come to that Allah
has caused the same preacher you come
and say to brother Eddie I want you to
preach from here The Message of Islam
yeah that was interesting uh Sheikh
Shakil uh we had the um the pastor they
could have accepted this uh before we
bring out our next guest you Gabriel
Romani I just want to touch upon his
point they had two other they had a few
other offers and they would have to had
Tara uh had uh tore down to make a car
wash or a uh a storage facility that was
really interesting is it and then the
past yeah yeah
yeah
and I think it it goes to to show that
people who believe in God want to see
this is also recognizing
the the the anti-religiousness that's
happening in the west where even you
have Christians who want to give the the
the facility to a house of worship right
even if it's not the same their same
religion at least their their in their
mindset they're saying these are people
who believe in God and believe in Jesus
Christ as we Muslims do so I think
people are are looking at you know
they've tried atheism they've tried so
many different things and even science
is not backing atheism as atheists used
to claim so there's so many I think
there's a pendulum shift right now in in
the United States of America and the
Outlook towards religion it's not the
80s not the 90s anymore
um and this is not just this church
itself but you know the the the church
that we person in New York City the
pastor themselves were happy that they
were giving it to us which is a mosque
um the same thing in Tampa the same
church did they were happy that it was
becoming a mosque and the name Jesus Son
of Mary Center so I think it's a
phenomenon I think today is it's a new
it's a new year it's 1444 and it's an
amazing time to launch the the dean
Central online and I think every single
Muslim can start the brand new year by
supporting and donating uh for Allah
subhana and start the new year fresh and
clean with an amazing Good Deed imagine
the dean Center that will outlive us
inshallah 5 10 15 20 100 years after
we're gone and the Next Generation the
generation after that will be continuing
to do this important work of clarifying
The Message of Islam uh and we will be
in our Graves getting the reward for
that so it's an honor that we have the
ability to support uh such an Endeavor
this is the true investment with an Roi
that is guaranteed by Allah thank you
very much let's uh without further Ado
bring on our next guest
our brother Gabriel Romani assalamu
alaikum
how are you doing brother alhamdulillah
go ahead the it's all you from here
for having me on I've known brother
Eddie for masha'allah what is it like
almost probably 18 years 17 years
mashallah yes time we've met was in
Chicago in one of the classes
and I did the first interview there
entitled Romanian loving Islam
alhamdulillah and since then we've been
in touch and we've done a lot of great
work together alhamdulillah
and I think what I wanted to say today
for the brothers and sisters
and that the importance of such a center
in the United States of America in the
West
from my perspective what I want to bring
to the table
is and I spoke to Eddie I'm going to see
Eddie as well think the next weeks
probably within two weeks inshallah
we're going to be recording some stuff
together with the lights are going to
meet
but what I would like to see and
hopefully we're going to see that is
more pastoral care more
uh mental health issues being addressed
that was alhamdulillah we know that
there's a lot of Doubt going in the
United States of America mashallah
Community has been doing a lot
Billboards Quran printing distributions
um pamphlets
tables outside in different Parks you
name it there's a lot of doubt that's
being done
one of the things we got to work on is
also in our community our brothers and
sisters the Muslims the existing Muslims
one of the greatest challenges today
that we find is mental health issues
okay you have to be
um
aware of it it is I mean what's the
point of bringing Muslims in only when
our Muslims are leaving
what's the point of just bringing people
then in dawa and then just recycling
them and others are having issues so
we're having a lot of problems within
our communities that need to be
addressed and I hope that such a center
goes beyond than just doing dawa to
non-muslims but actually doing to
Muslims and what is dawah
other than inviting
you know as the principal in Islam and
Hadith
those who are closer to are more
entitled to your good behavior
so a lot of dilemma have commented and
that was or Isla is more important
sometimes to our own people first than
to the others now we can do both in
parallel
but hopefully what I will try to
convince brother and we'll be discussing
this and he knows my work is to focus on
Mental Health
and building that helping having
counselors having just
ways for people to turn to the right
people with the right skills to add
family issues we need to have strong
families they're the building blocks of
the ummah
so that is something very very important
that's number one number two I really
believe
that we're addressing a lot of adults we
need to focus on our children
specifically our boys our boys are
suffering they're being emasculated day
and night
they don't have great role models today
who if you if I ask my students who do
you look up to or give me some
non-muslim we really need to start
putting in some strong programs
I'm not talking about ballet or
something like they're talking here
about like jiu jitsu martial arts
um camps for boys to become men from
Boys to Men we need them Allah you know
sisters might be like what about us
there's sisters have a a better way of
connecting there's more support for
sisters our boys are struggling how can
we expect for them to lead the community
in the next 20 to 30 years
if they don't know even what a man is I
mean there's also confusion these days
about who is a man so imagine that
so I hope that we can focus on that
building that masculinity that strength
in our voice and I know brother
mashallah having been an expert in Jiu
Jitsu for so many years trading on The
Graces and so on as is the right person
I thought with the right support cannot
do it alone there needs to be
cooperation in this there needs to be I
mean we have resources brothers and
sisters well like this one thing we
don't lack
we do not lack
resources at all
we have resources we just don't know how
to cooperate we just don't know how to
we just don't know how to make
so these are two things major things
that I would like to say to see so again
mental health issues being tackled
counseling for our ummah
and uh targeting our boys getting our
boys from Boys to Men there's so many
amazing programs and I'll be talking to
any about them as well that we can do
and with the center such that it can
accommodate that it can be an amazing
place for an for so many different
activities where people can feel safe
that their kids have an actual social
environment not just to hang around and
do nothing but has an objective a
curriculum
there's key performance indicators
things that can lead to the development
of a strong masculine leader within our
ummah Allah we're lacking that and last
but not least maybe 0.3 for you know our
brothers and sisters the families a
place for them to you know to be able to
feel safe again and to they themselves
be involved in dawa training development
and so on and so forth so these are
three things that I would personally
like to see from the center I know that
Eddie has a lot of plans mashallah and
I'm sure you guys have discussed many
things in these past three or hour three
hours now mashallah
but please if anything focus on the
first two points we need this I'm
telling you from
you know about what so now like almost
18 years of experience as a counselor
that we need to help our brothers and
sisters yes alhamdulillah I know that
the center is going to the dawa alhamdul
I know everyone likes to see shahada I
know alhamdulillah everyone likes to see
Christians embracing Islam and so on and
so forth
but trust me when I tell you that our
community needs help everywhere and it's
not easy to see the problems and to
understand the problems you need a
specific skill specific way to
allow people to open up and have the
courage to come and say hey I have a
problem I want to talk about it and also
takes a specific skill within in line
with the Quran Sunnah to be able to
tackle those problems
so Michelle I pray that Allah and this
and that you guys fulfill this purpose
inshallah
U thank you so very much okay you spoke
directly from your heart
and it really resonated well with all of
us he brought back some good memories
well going on look how time has flown by
when we first first met huh subhanallah
subhanallah
now you notice in a better in a better
Union inshallah I mean I mean I mean I
mean and I and I I look forward to
seeing you soon here in uh in Chicago
may Allah
I mean I mean this is a platform through
which we were able to address the issues
that many massage members may not be
comfortable or welcoming and this is the
platform where we are very passionate
and talking about the issues we are
desperately needed in our community in
these societies
so my beloved this is our opportunity to
bring this into existence so we can
address the issue that is desperately
needing our attention and if you believe
in this work need to be done now is the
time for us to support generously and
bring this dream into reality by helping
us
build and complete the project of Dean
Center transitioning from Dean's show to
Dean center now is the time and I really
would like to encourage all of you you
know the past history in this particular
church is that Allah has guided this
pastor he himself is saying that I would
like for this building to remain a house
of worship
Allah has even caused non-believers to
see the value in their efforts and the
work that is being done here what are we
waiting for now is the time for us to do
this may Allah make it easy for all of
us to continue to do this job and may
Allah bless brother Eddie with the long
healthy life with his strong Iman and
the spirit that he always have towards
this cause to continue to work for which
inshallah we are all looking forward to
and inshallah generations to benefit
from it now is the time to help
establish the dean center with the
beginning of the new year 1444 let this
1444 Mark as a history making here in
America inshallah
I would like to encourage all of our
Muslim Community consider giving
generously for this noble cause that is
desperately in need and need of Our Time
mega dawa Center is needed to address
the islamophobia effectively
to God brother Eddie through dinship has
been doing whose rich is now just as
with the bean show over 5 million
imagine if we give Eddie the dean Center
how much more we will be able to reach
and how many people are going to benefit
from it once Allah accepted any effort
from your side then he gives you another
project and that is a sign of acceptance
of the previous work brother ADI have
started his Dean show Allah Grant
acceptance to it now he gave him another
opportunity to have the dean Center to
serve the humanity it is our duty my
beloved to do whatever we can to support
and bring this into reality desperately
needed funds or few hundred thousand and
within with that we'll be able to bring
this entire
35
000 square foot building will come into
existence as a mega Tower Center here in
America that will serve Millions for
generations to come so my below please
do not miss out this opportunity to take
part in this noble cause a historical
thing that's about to take place please
donate generously as soon as possible
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
this happens to be the first day in the
new hijri calendar the new history year
Muharram the month of Allah the first
month in the Islamic calendar
and this is the year
1444 years after the Hijra of the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
and I want you to picture this
almost 1400 years ago
rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was sitting with his companions in the
desert
in the Arabian peninsula
in the desert in the Arabian peninsula
then he tells them
foreign
this religion will reach as far as the
day and the night reaches
in
this religion of Islam will enter every
single home on the face of this Earth
brothers and sisters in Islam
I just want you to picture that
picture that they are still in the
Arabian Peninsula they haven't even
gotten out of there
is telling them that
brothers and sisters in Islam we being
in America
is a testimony to what the prophet
salallahu alaihi wasallam said
and here we are opening massages
taking over churches which used to serve
polytheism
were taken over sights and places
lawfully legally according to the law of
the land so that we can spread Islam
more and more and more brothers and
sisters in Islam so we can contribute
more to the cause of Allah
brothers and sisters in Islam
you're being called today for an
emergency
to help
establish this Dean Center
this Center where we're planning brother
Eddie and his team planning to have a
Masjid
do you know what is the reward if you
contribute only the
size of a brick
or the value of a brick
to the building of a house of Allah
house of worship
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
says
whoever builds a house for the sake of
Allah even if it is the size of a bird
nest like a brick
will build for this person a house in
Jannah
your address will be Jannah brothers and
sisters in Islam not just the house but
the house in Jannah nothing A Street
random street here in on Earth
where you will not die
where you will not feel any more pain
anxiety
Do you want to build your house in
Jannah
contribute scholar said what does it
mean the prophet said a bird nest he
can't pray in a bird nest so they said
whoever contributes the value of a bird
nest so a lot of you today through this
noble cause Noble project
can have a house in Jannah if you
contribute as little as a birdness
brothers and sisters in Islam
brothers and sisters in Islam in this
Amiga Dean Center
we're gonna have a school
where we protect the
identity of our Muslim kids brothers and
sisters in Islam and you know quite well
now what is going on in the public
school system
it's becoming completely unsafe
for our children brothers and sisters in
Islam
first of all
the separation between the religion and
the system
is a main cause meaning that your
children will never receive anything
that would even hand to the existence of
a god of Allah
which is totally against the teachings
of Islam
and we know recently now how the moral
Decay the moral decline the moral defect
gotten into our school system regarding
morality regarding basic things which
our innate inherent
Citra
condemn and rebuke brothers and sisters
in Islam a school
protecting the next generation of this
ummah the children of those Muslim of
the Muslims brothers and sisters in
Islam a community center
a place
where you can come and join the rest of
the community members and bond with them
build that Brotherhood brothers and
sisters in Islam around the Masjid
around the school around the facility
and above all brothers and sisters in
Islam you're contributing to the spread
of Islam like the prophet mentioned that
it's going to end up entering every home
because of you
brother Eddie has been doing this for
years
for years we witnessed that
I have been a host on his show more than
one time he's been doing it for years
volunteering for the sake of Allah
educating the ummah and I know this
brother quite well brothers and sisters
in Islam he is very careful about what
he disseminates out there of information
he calls me all the time what do you
think about that what do you think about
that this is something that someone that
you can trust brothers and sisters in
Islam and I'm not praising him
but he has displayed his
uh keenness on disseminating
valuable
and authentic knowledge to the ummah to
the community
he addressed issues brothers and sisters
in Islam that needs to be addressed
he he did I I witnessed to that
now
he his experience has grown his team
Masha Allah is up and running now he can
offer this to the ummah brothers and
sisters in Islam imagine after we die
this place will stand out there in
Florida serving the cause of Allah after
all of us die even Eddie even me even
you everybody
uh this is what you call Sada kajeria
ongoing sadaka brothers and sisters in
Islam
healed the calls of Allah
brothers and sisters in Islam remember
when you spend in the calls of Allah
remember Allah will give it back to you
some of us may not believe that hence
three things I'm willing to take oath on
number one
your wealth will never decrease you're
gonna go right now and click donate
towards the Deen center right now
be certain
that Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala will
return that to you manifolds
beside it will be your reward
on the day of judgment
rasulullah sallallahu alaihi wasallam
says
the believer will be under the shade of
her sadata until Allah
settles the disputes and uh
arbitrate between the people yeah
brothers and sisters in Islam the son of
Adam says Mali Mali Mali my wolf my wolf
my wolf
what do you need the will force of Adam
to eat and to eat that's all but the
true wealth is what you spend in the
cause of Allah and what will stay for
you on the day of judgment one day
brothers and sisters in Islam the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam was
given a very nice Sheep by one of his
Neighbors
knew that the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam loves to eat the shoulder
so the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
in his way out he didn't want to keep
anything from it he said the eyes of
Slaughter it get somebody to slaughter
it and please distribute the meat to the
neighbors and the needy
when the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam return brothers and sisters in
Islam he asked what did you do with the
good with the shiba Aisha look she said
oh messenger of Allah all of it is gone
except the shoulder I saved the shoulder
for you you know what the prophet
all of it stayed
accept the shoulder
what you spend you see the money that
you're spending now
is what will stay for you
but whatever you keep for yourself
you're gonna spend it in this world and
Allah knows best if you're gonna spend
it wisely or not but this is your saving
with who with Allah
says
from you with his right hand
and he will grow it for you
like you grow up like you raise up a
horse a baby horse and so brothers and
sisters in Islam this is a course
[Music]
believe in Allah believe that the
religion of Allah will get all over the
place will enter every single house you
gotta believe that because the prophet
said that and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam does not speak randomly
he receives Revelations from Allah he
receives instructions from Allah to
speak out brothers and sisters in Islam
believe that
now
spend to make it happen
and spend on from what Allah
placed you as trustees over it it's not
your money
Allah given it to you spend it
spend it brothers and sisters in Islam
[Music]
help it guys help it make it it happened
guys we need to go next month out there
and have the first event insha Allah
we'll be talking about that so Allah and
show you the facility and show you where
the school is going to be where the
Masjid is going to be where's that could
you that our Center is going to be where
the library is going to be this is going
to be a hub for the ummah make it happen
I wanna before we bring on our next
guest yusha Evans I just want to see if
the audience can guess this is kind of a
old video here but if they can guess who
this uh
who this uh
one second young man is in this uh video
that I came across what the Muslims are
about yeah so tell us now now I got the
question I'll open the show and I said
look we got to read the questions look
at this Pearson has qualified God
willing to help give us some advice
people go to doctors they have a disease
or something but many of us we have the
disease of the heart and this is more
important because the pills might fix
you up and you might heal your bone if
it's broke but man when the heart is
Rusted it needs that Polish Polish so
let's get some polishing okay so tell
his assistant he says that message love
your show uh sister needs a push title
okay so she said for years my husband
has been growing and improving in his
Dean Dean the way of life of all the
messengers of God Islam so and for years
he has been nicely trying to get me to
where the hijab that's the fashion from
the seven Heavens from the crater right
so uh he's been for years trying to get
me to wear to hijab and for years I've
refused I just can't seem to find the
courage to wear it my parents are Muslim
times more cultural in Brackets it says
and it's strange but they are against
the hijab also and I feel they would
disown me if I put it on I'm also
nervous as to how my friends friends
would react it's eating away at me and I
feel a lot the Creator keeps sending me
signs now the question is am I being
ungrateful by not wearing it what about
my parents what am I going to do
okay
let's turn this into a program I thought
we can discuss this and inshallah at the
end the system here her heart will
soften and she's going to run and put
the can I can I tell you something that
I thought about an abbrevious show with
you but here it is again
a young man
look at this now you know
yeah
and we'll see you this weekend
I'll be there in Chicago helping out
guys come on guys let's make this happen
yes one more month is left here to do
closings
by the grace of Allah by the help of
Allah I'm certain Allah will make it
happen for the um
and we have our next guest coming up
here who's going to take it away he's
also one of the ogs we call it the
original guests on The Dean show so you
saw Evans how you doing my brother
how you doing bro you sound good
alhamdulillah Crystal Clear thank you
for joining us go ahead and take it away
yeah it's been uh it's been a long time
Eddie I think um I think the first time
I was on The Dean show you had just
started doing English uh and and I think
before that you were just doing Bosnian
uh programs I think this was like
2007-ish
late 2006 for Panama so we've been at
this for a long time
um and you know you know I've always
been a big supporter of what you do
brother you know I mean and I've always
enjoyed the way you approached the dean
in a very logical and in a very you know
realistic manner for an American
audience and it's something that that
was much needed back then and is and is
even much more needed to date you know
for for people to understand how Islam
can can holistically and realistically
improve upon the status and value of
people's lives and that's that's
something that that's so missing in in
today's world is you know especially
after the pandemic we realize that the
world is in pain you know I mean there
are so many people that are lost there's
so many people that are hurting there
are so many people that are going
through so many things and
they're they're turning to everything
they're turning to drugs they're turning
to alcohol they're turning to medication
they're turning to the world you know
they're turning to clubs they're trying
whatever it is they're turning to is
only and I've said this for many years
it's like trying to put sand in the
ocean and hope that you will fill it you
know I mean you could spend a lifetime
doing that and you're never going to
displace enough amount of water to do
any any real benefit but the thing about
Islam is that
it completely fills that that hole in
that Gap in people's lives and I know
this because I was not a Muslim for the
first 18 years of my life and accepting
Islam is I I believe one of the
contributing factors the reason why I'm
still here today because I was on a very
dark path and Islam has made me a whole
person it's made me someone who not only
understands my own purpose to serve my
Creator but it's allowed me to
understand why I'm here on this Earth
not only to serve the one who created me
but to serve other people and that's
that's what I believe and we haven't
even had a long discussion about this
Eddie but I'm almost 100 sure that
that's the purpose behind the dean
Center is to help people is to be
helpful to people because that's that's
what we need to do that that's the goal
is to help people because one of the
things that I think we've forgotten
about with our religion is that yes
we're supposed to serve our creator but
one of the most beautiful ways to serve
the Creator one of the most beautiful
ways to serve the Creator and we learn
this through the son of the Prophet
Allah one of the most beautiful ways to
serve the Creator is to be service to
his creation to be to be service to his
creation service to the creationist
servitude to the one who created them
and that's a lot of what we are missing
in the Dallas scene you know we're we're
trying to convince everybody of the
ideological argument of Islam you know
brain wrestling but in reality what
people want to know today is how can
Islam help me how can Islam better my
life how can Islam better my situation
how can Islam heal what's going on in my
mind how can Islam heal what's going on
in my heart how can Islam heal what's
what's going on in my life and and
that's where we need to be targeting and
that's that's what I've always seen
Eddie try to do is tackle real real
world problems with real world Solutions
is what Islam has we keep talking about
the ideological argument of Islam but
within the the tenets of the faith
within the Quran and within the son of
the Prophet
is also the answers to the problems that
are facing Humanity it's also the
answers the problems that are facing
humanity and we should want to help that
we should want to help that because we
are part and parcel to this world we are
raising children I have three children
gorilla
who are being raised in this world Eddie
I know you have children as well one of
your sons I've played I've played worse
one with him a few times you know we
want to leave this world better than we
found it and we're not doing that just
out of some you know self-fulfilling
reason so that we can feel better about
ourselves we're doing this because we
know that this is service to the one who
created us this is a service to the one
who created us so brothers and sisters
support this project there are not
enough and when people say you know like
oh we're building Masters here but it
doesn't matter we need more we need more
there is not enough places of service
for people to understand the religion of
Islam from an American perspective from
people who are born and raised here who
live here and who are part and parts of
this community we need more and more and
more so brothers and sisters who are
watching this right now support this
project like I said I've known Eddie
personally now for 16 years I mean I was
joking about we were on the phone the
other day talking about this and I was
joking about it you know that we've come
to a long way you know the dean show has
come such a long way production has come
such a long way in the very beginning I
remember it was like me and she Hadley
were some of the original guests like we
were coming out we literally were
walking out of like a coat closet you
know to enter into the studio uh you
know it was a whole different it was a
whole different ball game back then but
that what shows the sincerity
is that it's still here you know things
that are sincere stay things that are
sincere things that you do that are
sincerely for the sake of Allah
those things remain and that's why you
see longevity
and what Eddie's been doing that's why
you see longevity in the dean show
that's why you see longevity in some of
the guests that you've seen today like
our former guest Imam Karim abuzad who
I've known also for about the same
amount of time 16 years since he was
Imam at pgma in Virginia people who are
sincere they stick around they stay
around because Allah accepts their
efforts so brothers and sisters if
you're watching this today make sure you
click on the link make sure you give it
doesn't matter if it's five thousand
dollars if you can afford it or if it's
five dollars what matters is the
intention and the sincerity because what
Allah can do with sincere amounts of of
your effort you is is is is is
unimaginable I've seen it so many times
and I've been fundraising for so many
things for so many years and one thing
that's never ever failed me and I've
always given a challenge to this I've
challenged people so many times when I
go and do fundraisers you know that the
prophet salallahu made a promise and he
said he didn't promise about many things
in this life but he said there are a few
things in this world that I'll take an
oath upon and one of them is that you
cannot decrease your wealth by giving
charity that you cannot decrease wealth
by giving charity so when you give
charity it is only to increase your
wealth and I tell Muslims that even if
you're in a position to where you know
you're struggling financially I remember
one of my earliest teachers he was one
of the people who introduced dawah to me
and and what it meant and what it how
important it was he also got like use of
Esther disvolved
um
he used to tell me if you're struggling
with anything in this world to give
charity
and I used to be like this makes I
called him one time and said look uh I'm
I'm I'm I'm struggling to pay some of my
bills can you give me because he was
paying me to help him at that time I
said can you just give me a little bit
of Advance he said give Sada I said bro
I'm telling you I have like ten dollars
in my bank account he said give five
dollars of that in South and watch what
Allah does with the other five and
wallahi it's never failed it's never
failed when you do something sincerely
for the sake of Allah and you give
something sincerely for the sake of
Allah whether it's your money your time
your knowledge your energy your skills
whatever it might be when it's given for
the sake of Allah is going only going to
increase it it's only going to increase
it so brothers and sisters out there if
you want to increase your pleasure of
Allah if you want to increase your
wealth if you want to increase the
goodness in your life if you want to do
better in your business give for the
sake of Allah because we are all in this
together we all learn this together the
prophet sallallahu is like one body you
know Allah says
um
so we are all in this together Eddie I
have no doubt insha Allah have no doubt
that this Center is going to be
established because I have seen what
you've been able to do with much of
nothing from the beginning brother and I
know that your dedication to to serving
the dean and serving The Tao and trying
to help uh people understand Islam in
plain simple English is is is uh is is
is unsurpassed in many ways so may Allah
bless you guys in this effort may Allah
Grant you goodness in this life and I
look forward to and I told you last time
anytime bro Tampa Florida is beautiful
so anytime you want your brother you
should come down and see the center in
Tampa Florida I will be there insha
Allah
foreign
let's go real back real quick I want to
see we played this uh with the previous
guest I'm going to do this with uh don't
embarrass me like that no no no no no
let's just let me see if people can
guess this one the camera's cut out all
the movies
[Music]
which means peace be unto you welcome to
another episode of the dean show my name
is indeeden I'm your host Eddie
and this is the all-new show on Islam
and Muslims thank you for coming to the
source to learn about
the most misunderstood way of life in
the world today which is practiced by
over 1.5 billion
human beings all around the world
so we want to help you develop a better
understanding
and there are certain issues
and myths that we like to clear up here
on the show one of them which is
prominent in the world today is the idea
that God Almighty the Creator can be a
man so we're going to be discussing this
topic with our next guest
and giving you
some of the
top 10 reasons why
God Almighty cannot be a man
one note here is that we're going to be
discussing something that might be a
little sensitive to some people
about one who is beloved to our hearts
his name is Jesus
we want to note that everyone knows
before we start that we love Jesus we're
trying to deliver issue for Christians
Muslims there he goes why did anybody
recognize this younger number one reason
is that God cannot be born God did not
come into existence he's always existed
he did not come into existence from
non-existence he was not born he was not
sure can you recognize it's always been
before there was even a thing I love it
the good spirit
the Eddie well we were young men we were
young men back then bro you're still
young
yeah I'm still young but I I tuned my
camera so that you can't see all the
Grays in my beard now
alhamdulillah but Eddie we've been going
since back then bro that's why I'm
telling you I know what I I know that
this can happen you can do this
inshallah to be able to come from all of
that like literally we we this this is
the colomination this is actually
putting some brick and mortar together
and and doing something that is needed
that is needed we we need we need more
brick and mortar places where people can
come to learn about the dean and also
people who want to be involved in help
spreading the message can can have help
because that's one of the biggest things
we find today is that people are like
how do I get involved you know I mean
and we just don't have enough resources
here in the states to be able to do that
and that is why something like the dean
Center is needed because we need that
Hub to where people can get involved and
and people can can get behind what
you're doing in Chama I really
appreciate thank you for the support
inshallah we'll see you there when we
get the keys inshallah you know I'll be
there bro Tampa Florida no problem
especially in winter time because I live
in Minnesota no problem we'll get some
vitamin D in the Sun get some vitamin D
inshallah may Allah bless you I mean you
too just like ahead thank you brother
okay
good morning brother I would like to
take a minute here to thank all the
donors that we have donated for this
whatever the amount that you have
donated during this presentation may
Allah great acceptance and reward you
many for in this life and the Hereafter
and make this appropriate charity for
you not only but for your own generation
progeny till the day of judgment to
benefit from but I'd like to take a
moment to address this issue we have
only few hundred thousand dollars left
to come up with before the end of August
we will take care of it but I would like
to appeal to those individuals
professionals well-to-do people who we
have not yet reached when you receive
this message please consider giving
generously if you can if not then at
least give us a call and let us know
that you will remain as a standby as a
Hassan we are open to receive any Hassan
from you as well so we can have the
assurance that we can go ahead and close
this deal while continue to appeal to
the generous donors to give donation in
the name of Allah
so we can pay this one off if and when
inshallah when we have raised all the
funds for that so we need donors we need
individuals who can give a person for us
500 000 is not a big deal for many
professionals out there the money
sitting out there in the bank we don't
even know what you do with it you don't
want to donate 100 that's quite all
right but give us a call so you can
offer us that comfort and confidence
that we need to continue to move forward
if we don't end up meeting our goal of
raising all these remaining until the
first week of September we would like to
hear from you saying brother we got your
back you're going to close this no
matter what if you give us this
motivation inshallah
it will encourage other donors out there
many donors were saying what if you
don't close I want you all donors those
who he even have given a dollar or ten
thousand dollar or fifteen thousand
dollars donation came from Far East and
West and Middle East may Allah reward
you immensely they asked us what if you
don't end up raising all the funds we
said to them we have donors who are
lined up who are assuring us insha Allah
you will close
that is the assurance that we would like
for all of you to have rest assured like
the brother said Evans that we will
close this inshallah with the donation
but again for the further projects and
everything that we need we need the
Hassan also for people to come forward
and talk about it one last thing
inshallah inshallah if we can have 500
000 it's really not that big of a deal
for the healthcare professionals I am in
healthcare I know I understand that how
much money we make and how much we can
give for the sake of Allah and I want
you to know that this organization the
dean Center is a tax exempt whatever you
give for the sake of Allah you can also
claim on your taxes
business people out there entrepreneurs
out there you we have funds sitting on
the side that we would look for the
opportunity to claim on our taxes here
is your opportunity to do that
so race not the movement and opportunity
to utilize this to your advantage
inshallah and give generously
let's bring out our next guest we got a
couple more guests uh we had so many
people wanting to come forward and
participate uh apologies to many who we
couldn't have on we'd be here all night
so let's bring on our next guess who has
some some beautiful words of
encouragement to say and then we'll
bring on former Christian Pastor Samuel
on the program after this one
with you from the Islamic Association of
North Texas in Dallas and uh I want to
give a shout out for support to our dear
beloved brother Eddie rejevich and his
Dean
I encourage you and everyone else that
you can think of that can help him to
get this place open so that the great
work of what he's already doing can be
multiplied by the magnitude of having a
proper state-of-the-art facility that's
going to be able to host everything of a
Masjid of the studio for the work that
the dean show is doing as well as a
training facility a a gym and and the
likes that can also be inshallah
available for our young adults and our
youth and anyone else that's going to
inshallah to be able to Avail the
training and and the benefits of what
are going to be there we do ask that you
be generous and you give and be any
lessons this is certainly work that is
dealing with the religion it's a cat
eligible anything of which you have help
and have your intention be that you're
looking to continue to promote the
teaching of
Muhammad rasulullah and that you're
looking to preserve that within the
ummah as well as share that with the
rest of the non-muslims that are around
us and know that Allah
all appreciative and that whatever you
help in give an even and spreading the
news of it that Allah is the one that
appreciates and what he acknowledges of
your services of your donations of your
support
is the best to reward you and bless you
for it in this life as well as in the
next for here after in the Hereafter for
eternity and to ask
that he bless each and every one of you
and that he also continue to bless our
dear brother Eddie and all that are
working with him to help make the dean
Center come true and to bless it with
all that it's going to be of Allah
giving his support and now we have Imam
Musa this is a very special young man
here who's with us former Christian
Pastor who was with the writing on the
propeller planes with uh who was that
Jerry Farwell I don't know if you heard
of Jerry was it Jerry Farwell yeah
Jerry paulwell and now he's on a d show
to share a few minutes with us
welcome
I'm coming coming to you from Oman uh
from Muscat Oman
and I want to uh just congratulate you
Eddie on the work you're doing the work
you're doing is important to the entire
Uma uh we're all held by your work and
we look forward to your success your
success is our success
may God bless you and encourage you you
know there are so many problems out
there today facing Muslims
uh one of them is uh the many tragedies
affecting Muslim youth around the world
uh I go to Norwich
in or to Norway Oslo Norway if a couple
of years ago
and the Oslo Islamic Center I'm speaking
there and I needed to take a break so I
told Imam farrukh please I need to go
for a walk so I went down the street I'm
walking down the street and there's a
young Muslim lad he's only about 18
years old leaning against the wall his
eyes are blurry
I asked him I said what it looks like
you need help and he started crying help
me help me help me
I just held on to him for a few minutes
he's got needle tracks going up and down
his arm
I said what's your name he said Muhammad
these are problems faced by Muslim youth
around the world
we need to open up the situation so that
they we can get them back on the
straight path of faith
and get them help
this problem is not just peculiar to
Norway it's pecu it's uh it's indicative
of what's going on in Saudi Arabia today
uh we see hundreds of Muslim youth at
Bremen prison
also they're there for drugs and alcohol
I asked them well how did you get
started on
and they said oh we saw an American
movie we thought it would really be cool
yeah now they're addicted
so this is a problem and this is a way
that I know the dean show through your
broadcast and through the pull of your
heart Eddie
you can help us get these kids back get
them back on path
uh
shaytan is our number one enemy
and he wants to pull people left and
right through temptation
he wants to get them off the path but we
want to get them back on the path
the other area where we're working it's
just for unbelievers people who know
nothing about Islam
but we want them to know that our
prophet
our prophet
was a human rights activist it's
indicative of what happened in Medina in
the very beginning
the Medina declaration our Prophet peace
and blessings be upon him
he was a civil rights activist who
remember his last message
a White's not above not above a black a
Black's not above a white all races are
equal in the in the face of God's
God's grace and mercy
uh he taught that women uh women he
taught women's rights
at the time of the Prophet uh many
children were being just female children
who were being left in the desert to die
but through prophet Muhammad an end was
brought to that and women were given the
property rights and given the right to
to to be leaders in their own Society
um
our profit
was an animal rights activist wow
he was an animal rights activist
remember the woman The Prostitute was
she dipped her shoe in the water and
gave a drink to a dog
he said she's going to be
uh she's gonna
because of her work and because of the
love of the animals that she had she's
going to be in Jeddah
uh we're
very happy at Muslim voice for beasts to
say that our Prophet was a peace
activist not pro-war
the world looks at him
it's with scathing eyes but
we can proudly say he was anti-war he
said you can fight if somebody you can
defend yourself if somebody is attacking
you but you can't go out and fight an
aggressive war against your enemy
against any enemy
and if our Prophet were alive today
he'd be campaigning against nuclear
weapons
this is a totally different perspective
on Prophet Muhammad than what the world
has
uh you know nuclear weapons kill
innocent people they destroy crops and
animals and all of that's against the
law
in Islam
but we're proudly here to say and to
encourage youth around the world Muslim
youth to be leaders in all of these
areas
and from our offices new offices in
Washington D.C
with the help of ASAP Hussein we're
going to be educating Muslim youth to be
leaders in human rights civil rights
women's rights in the in the field of of
animal rights
and also in peacemaking
I took a group of Muslim youth to
Hiroshima Japan a few years ago and we
bowed and prayed in ground zero for an
end of nuclear weapons
um news media was watching
the TV cameras were going
and some of the journalists came to her
afterwards us afterwards and were
laughing and saying you got to be
kidding if you want us to believe this
but it's absolutely fact
absolute fact
Sheikh will be interviewing those
leaders that you're taking them around
soon inshallah at the dean center with
the dean showing volunteers thank you
very much for being with us give myself
thank you thank you God bless you all
and may God give you Victory quickly and
soon
foreign
all right we are coming down to our last
two guests let's go ahead and bring
here on the D shows sister
how are you we're good alhamdulillah how
are you I'm doing amazing masha'allah
you're doing such an incredible job with
this fundraiser with this Emmett the
vision that you have for the dean Center
I'm really excited to be a part of this
masha'allah thank you very much my luck
sent from all of us ameen ameen
so uh go ahead it's just a week uh we
were at the last two and hamdulillah
we're coming to an end and it's very
nice uh we couldn't go ahead and close
it out without having you on also just
like a lot so we'll go ahead and um let
you uh take it from here sure sure
inshallah you know um so Paula I want
you to dream with me a little bit okay I
want you to dream of a society where we
have youth that are so confident so
proud of being a Muslim that they are
able to contribute to society they are
not weakened by their peers they are not
affected by the social media and they
are able to not only stand strong and
maintain their religion but they're able
to impact positively the Muslim the
non-muslims and even the Muslim
Community how amazing would that be to
how have a society where our youth are
proud healthy Pride right healthy pride
and they are strong in their conviction
and imagine parents who are connected
with their kids who know how to engage
them where they will come to them when
they have problems that they will be
there that they will have the knowledge
on how to connect with their children
now sadly we are far from that we are so
far from that because on a daily basis
I'm a faith-based counselor for those of
you who may not know
and what you see what I see on a daily
basis is that hard-working good
practicing Muslim families who have
devoted their lives to the dean they
come to me devastated crying and just
completely floored because their kids
have left Islam their kids have sexual
identity issues that their kids are
taking off their hijab they're losing
their faith they're cutting ties running
away from home there's you know there's
self-harm there's even suicide attempts
of suicide now you see this and when you
think about what is it I mean they're
totally baffled because they think I you
know I thought I was doing the right
things I thought that my kids are
turning out fine but when you look at it
you see that there are many reasons for
this first of all there's a lack of
support there's lack of Role Models
right there's not a good solid Community
when they go to the mosque a lot of
times they're shunned they're criticized
they're told to lie like you know sit in
the back or be quiet and you know not to
be as engaged they're not sometimes
welcomed in the community they feel
alienated right they feel alienated for
being different the islamophobia makes
them feel kind of a shame to be Muslim
they feel embarrassed to be recognized
as a Muslim so they want to take away
any identity they don't want to take
away the hijab they want the Islamic
names to be taken away they don't want
to be seen with their families right and
it's about having like and not having
any kind of Islamic Pride so that is why
I mean this Dean Center is so important
in our community you know it is awesome
because I've known brother Eddie
mashallah for years and I I do trust
them and I feel like he has been working
so hard for the Muslim Community for
years now and now he has this Vision he
has a vision that I'm so happy to
support and I Inc encourage every single
one of you to support because we need to
Save Our Youth and why is this Dean
Center so important it's because it
provides an alternative there is an
alternative instead of hanging out and
being in an environment that is not
conducive to the dean you're in an
environment you're providing a healthy
alternative and it's always important
you know we're in on a health kick and
we're always we're actually just today
talking about how you need to have a
healthy alternative and maybe someone
cannot give up sugar okay let's use monk
fruit but if you don't give them an
alternative and say no more sugar right
people are going to freak out so we need
to have an alternative okay you're not
going to this club but you're going to
come to this Islamic club and this is
something that we have seen within the
U.S that the non-muslims have really
really embraced and they have done this
and that's why it makes it like
appealing right and the fact that you or
masha'allah providing a place that is
going to provide guidance right there's
mentorship you have individuals that the
youth can look up to that they can say
oh my gosh this person he's so cool he's
so accomplished oh my gosh you know and
I I remember when my kids we were in
Egypt for a few years and I put them in
a leadership camp and those moments
being with these young adults that had
you know they had the leadership they
were fun they were cool they were
religious that impacted them so strongly
and so we need to have this we need that
mentorship we need a positive
Association to the dean
telling our kids if you don't pray
you're going to hell if you do this
you're just Haram and it's all Haram
Haram Haram with no fun Associated to it
we're gonna lose them and a lot of
people have already lost it so making
sure you know when you have a community
center like this masha'allah first of
all it builds that Islamic Pride it
makes you feel happy to be a Muslim and
it's a place where you can bring your
non-muslim friends how important is that
a lot of times people are a little bit
you know reluctant like where can I take
my non-muslim friend because I don't
know how people are going to behave I
don't know what the environment's gonna
be like so to have a place like this
where you can bring the non-muslims and
you can bring your friends and imagine
the dawah imagine the dawa and you can
you know you can just strengthen
that um the relationship right with the
non-muslims so I really feel that you
know it's a unique opportunity to be a
part of the fabric of this society's
dawa Center because you know in a lot of
Muslim countries the mosques are
government-funded and people may not
have the opportunity to help a place
help build a place like this so what I
encourage you to do so whether you have
kids or not you need to donate whether
you live in Florida or not donate
whether you will directly benefit or not
you need to donate because it will be
amazing to be a part of this just
imagine it I want you to hear the
cha-ching you know we get excited when
we're in business and we're you know if
you get okay sales sales you hear the
cha-ching cha-ching well I want you to
get that excitement about the edger
imagine the edger you get every time
someone Embraces Islam you're a part of
it every time a sister puts on the hijab
you get a share of that every time that
someone is prevented from committing
suicide and a person is prevented from
let's say harming themselves or leaving
the dean you will share in the reward
how amazing is that so we need to in
whatever capacity don't think of any
amount being too small whatever capacity
I want you to donate to this cause and
make sure that you give generously and
realize that you know we as a community
need to step up right we need to step up
we need to provide an environment for
our youth and not just you know this I
mean definitely what uh you know brother
Eddie is doing in providing this Center
is so critical and we need that we need
that in you know all the different
communities
and wouldn't it be great if as parents
we could connect with the youth and have
that positive impact wouldn't it be
great if we had the emotional
intelligence if we had some ability to
connect with them and make this a very
positive experience and I saw the need
in that and I have created a global
support group it's a mindful Hearts
Academy if anyone wants to improve
themselves as parents because it starts
at the home right so we need to work on
ourselves to help build our children and
then to help build a community so what I
really encourage you to do is support
this cause you're almost there mashallah
35
000 square feet and I think you have 700
000 remaining inshallah is that correct
less than that less than that all right
so masha'allah you're almost there and
it's it's a pleasure to be a part of
this masha'allah
thank you so very much we really needed
your word of inspiration as a woman as a
sister as a mother as a mentor Masha
Allah you really addressed the issue
that was very much needed and it is
these kind of issues that can be
addressed through these channels
inshallah right right inshallah may
Allah give you success until and it's a
pleasure to be on here thank you for
being here thank you I mean thank you
very much sister for your support for
being with us we'll see you tomorrow
uh brother Eddie is going to be my guest
inshallah which is like a look here
looking forward to it thank you so much
and we're almost out of time let's go
ahead and um hear
from another prominent figure in the
community uh before we bring him on
let's go ahead and let this video play
for you with uh another one of our
sisters here
I'm so excited the dean show okay is
about to become the dean Center I pray
to Allah that this happens probably like
you I have been a fan of the dean show
for more than a decade it's brought us
some of the best most consistent content
to do with people accepting the dean and
really good information about Islam From
the Inside Out mashallah Eddie I'm
absolutely with you and the team
inshallah everybody get behind this
they're talking about having a fully
functional TV Center for dower a prayer
space and an athletic Hall athletic
center the sisters need this space as
well you know I'm a I actually like gyms
but I don't like going because of the
environment there so to go to somewhere
like this I hope it's the first of many
I'm gonna support this the dean show
becoming the dean Center little get
behind this let's grow the dean
thank you thank you masha'allah yes
indeed let's grow The Deen through
support of the dean Center inshallah let
us support generously inshallah we
really need to raise These funds my
brother and sisters and we can make it
happen now is the time to do show our
support in action it is time to make and
take action in Allah
many of you know Eddie the dean's show
name hasn't changed because the message
will stay the same the dean and that's
exactly what he has been consistently
calling to so this effort is long
overdue Masjid Jim and Dallas Center all
of this is manifestation of the Deen
providing for the Mind Body and Soul
with this gym subhanallah as we know
Eddie has been involved in martial arts
for over 10 years we know the dean show
has been here for 10 years plus let's
let's donate to this cause and realize
that this definitely is a manifestation
of our ibadah of giving for what Allah
has given us and giving it back to
something that he loves as you've seen
with the work that he has done being
consistent and in having Integrity with
this message of telling people about
Allah from different walks of life and
he definitely compliments the ummah when
we look at the presence of Islam and
Muslims in America let's donate to this
beautiful beautiful idea that we see he
has the caliber and the integrity and
the wherewithal to see it through may
Allah bless you all for your donation
for your contribution for spreading the
link of this message to people to where
they can give to Allah
by giving to ones that call to Allah
don't forget to support this beautiful
beautiful effort
thank you
all right mamusa we got one last guest
let's go ahead and bring him on and then
we'll close it up with uh with yourself
uh making another appeal and let's bring
on
mohammedawi here Muhammad shanawi
take it away
oh we lost him hold on one second
where'd he go
so let's uh bring that again Muhammad we
is up here with us
for having me uh Eddie and the whole
team down there Bismillah alhamdulillah
We Begin the name of Allah all praise
and glory be to Allah and may his finest
peace and blessings be upon All His
prophets and Messengers and all those
who adhere to their guidance until the
last day
you know I uh struggle to decline an
invitation uh to present and support how
I can with insha Allah what will be an
HQ and a hub uh and a megaphone for the
dawa for inviting to the path of Allah
uh in these lands that I am of the
persuasion that the vast majority of
Americans have not yet been given an
honest look at Islam an honest chance to
consider Islam for themselves and so I
pray that Allah enables Eddie and his
team to
turn this Dean Center into a a model for
correctly sharing the treasure that is
Islam with the world and that Allah
allows the Ripple effects of this
initiative to benefit people far and
wide until the day of judgment
you know I just wanted to share a uh a
reminder regarding
a very uh pertinent verse in the book of
Allah in the Quran regarding dawah and
how Dara inviting to Allah is not is not
the work of the prophets just the
prophets or the scholars just the
scholars or the preachers rather this is
part and parcel of being Muslim this is
part and parcel of being a follower of
the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam that's Inseparable from calling
to his path so at the very end of the
chapter of Joseph Surat Yusuf in the
Quran Allah the most high says
peace be upon him say to them people
need to understand this say to them
this is my path and the path is about to
be described here what is the sacred
path of prophethood what does it look
like what does it mean to walk on it say
to them this which we have not yet
explained is my path and of course the
path of the Prophet is not anyone's path
right this is the path of God God put
him on this path and had him be the call
dollar to this path
and those who follow this path are the
cream of the crop of humanity and those
who will have the greatest share and be
most deserving of the word prosperity in
this world and salvation in the next
say o Muhammad peace be upon him this is
my path
my path is that I invite to Allah that's
the path of the prophet
and you're inviting to Allah means
you're inviting to the Creator you're
inviting to almighty God you're not
inviting to your culture you're not
inviting to your ideas you're not
inviting to your opinions you're not
calling someone to Islam because you
happen to be Muslim no you're calling
people to Islam
because your Prophet lived for this and
was sent by God for this and because the
heavens and the Earth were created for
this
and if you analyze and study the
prophet's life how genuine and sincere
he was from beginning to end to calling
people to Allah it's something truly
remarkable it's the most evident aspect
of his character most obvious you know
driving force in his personality upon
becoming a prophet is bringing people to
the message of God
you know you you think of uh the young
Jewish boy
in in so authentically reported that
there was a young Jewish boy who used to
serve the prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him help him with things uh and then he
fell sick and it turned out to be a
fatal illness and when they told him
this young Jewish boy is dying the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon Him rushes to his house uh and the
narrator says and the narrator was a
young man and the prophet peace be upon
him in his 50s or 60s the narrator is
saying I lost my breath trying to keep
up with the prophet Muhammad peace he
sprinted he raced to this young boy's
house and he raced there and he said to
the young boy
is worthy of worship but the one true
God
and even though the the father of this
boy was not Muslim he was Jewish as well
uh in a moment of sort of Parental uh
honesty right parental concern he turned
to his son and said I will cast him
listen to Muhammad
Saiyan is worthy of worship with Allah
meaning become Muslim and so the young
boy says and then he dies and the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon Him
leaves that house beaming with Joy
saying all praise be to Allah once again
he's not taking credit for it but look
at also you know his sense of relief
that this young boy was saved right he
said all praise be to Allah who saved
him yes through me but he saved him from
the fire
think about that what does this young
boy serve in terms of the state why
would the head of state do this because
he is not a Statesman even though he
served as one right his primary mission
is I call to Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
even you think of the Prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him when he himself Lost
the Child a toddler Ibrahim his young
son people began to say because on the
day of the death of Ibrahim uh the a
solar eclipse happened it went dark
during the daytime so people began to
say that the skies are saddened by the
death of the son of the prophet of God
like you get it right and so
he didn't say this the prophet didn't
say this someone else said it and he was
very busy even emotionally unavailable
uh you would imagine him to be but still
he did not even allow them on a day when
he was grieving to say that he walked
out of his house and ascended the altar
or the pulpit and said the sun and the
moon are signs of God he caused them to
Eclipse sometimes to strike fear in the
hearts of his slaves meaning it's a
display of his power right
he created this Earth and he can take it
all away and the universe itself will
end one day and will be arriving at the
last day the day of judgment the Day of
Reckoning so it's a sign of God these
Cosmic events that God ordains he says
they don't eclipse for the death or the
life of anyone don't try to interpret
this in any superstitious way that a
great man was born today a great man has
died today and therefore Eclipse he
wouldn't let them he made sure that the
message did not pivot on him but it
pivoted and directed to God yes he was
sort of our Earthly pivot through his
example we worship God but we don't set
these Larger than Life uh expectations
or understandings about even him he
wouldn't let that happen that's how
sincere he was to his call he calls to
Allah there is a clear distinction he
came to make between Creator and
creation I call to Allah and even in his
dying breaths he warned the people of
you know falling into what to the Jews
and Christians fell into of grave
worship and worshiping the Saints and
otherwise and he said you know don't you
dare turn my grave into a shrine that is
worshiped you know instead of God you
know don't do this you worship the one
true God that you do not see he is you
know unseen in this world it's the test
of believing in the Unseen and it is the
greatest reward of the Hereafter for the
Believers to be able to see the face of
their lord
and so say to them this is my path the
path of the Prophet my path is that I
call to Allah the verse continues to say
Allah upon clear insight and I know what
I'm doing I'm calling to Allah the way
Allah taught me I'm being tactful I'm
being strategic I'm being considerate
I'm accessing people's hearts by God's
permission you know through my character
through connecting with them on a very
human level that's of the values of you
know a project like like the dean Center
a localized dawa initiative this will
allow us to do so much more than what
the sort of the austere and weird online
space does it's impersonal it is not as
considerate of people's sort of
sensitivities or people's struggles and
otherwise and so the prophet Muhammad
used to build real relationships as part
of the Insight God gave him through
which he could invite to his path
connect with people on a very human
level be it their assistance and then
extend to them what is of greatest
assistance for them which is the
religion of Allah and his guidance
and then it says say this is my path my
path is I call to God I call to God upon
Insight upon clear knowledge me and
those who follow me and I'll close out
with that because if you're a follower
of the Prophet Muhammad peace and
blessings be upon him then you have to
call to his path as well and it it it's
sort of telling you what you should
already know when you believe in
something you call to it if someone were
to say this is the best restaurant and
you don't believe that you say no that's
the best restaurant that one has way
better steaks or burgers or salads or
whatever or desserts you know when you
believe this is a perfect match for you
for marriage the youngsters become these
automatic lawyers attorneys making an
awesome case to their parents why this
is a good fit for me so part and parcel
of believing in Islam is not being able
to sit tight yes you're going to be
strategic yes you're not going to strain
relationships but you're going to try
your very best to look for opportunities
to work around people's defense
mechanisms and give them for their sake
not your sake for their sake what is in
their best interests in terms of the
purpose and meaning of life and the end
goal of Felicity in the Hereafter so may
Allah allow for the team at the dean
Center and their current projects and
Beyond to be a mechanism for that and an
instrument for Allah's guidance going
above and beyond uh
in reaching uh people that are unaware
of it in this day and age good luck to
you all and you're in our prayers insha
Allah
pick up there are over 300 million
Americans that don't know what Islam is
this is why we are opening the dean
Center the first of its kind 35
000 square foot daoa center and Masjid
to show America the Beautiful Message of
Islam inshallah with your help and
donations we can close on the property
launch Nationwide Dao programs a
state-of-the-art Production Studio for
online content and an on-site dawa
Center to show what true Islam is donate
right now may God Almighty Allah reward
all of you
[Music]
this is so beautiful
and he I'm very excited and very happy
and grateful to Allah
for the participations of the issue from
across the globe the divers
ity that we have experienced I have
never seen any show that we have such a
diversity and the support from all walks
of life that is where it shows the
universality of the beautiful message of
an Islam and then being Center is
staying connected so dear viewers you're
not supporting that one individual
called brother Eddie rather you know
that Eddie is not alone in this cause
all of the brothers and Scholars across
the globe supports believes and believe
that this is the need of our time and
now is the time for us to do what is
needful Time for Action my beloved let
us have that needed funds to close this
building and start working you know the
interesting thing is that everybody have
ideas to do the job but here we already
have the plan and the record to prove
that we have worked in this particular
area and all we need is to help us
strengthen our hands so we can continue
to deliver this effectively to the
masses now is the time I beloved to do
whatever we can to support this noble
cause insha Allah
hey mamusa thank you very much
for being with us here we are over four
going on four and a half hours
and that's it that was our last guest
we're gonna go ahead and conclude akibi
would not have pulled it through without
the support of those hidden team of the
dean
work all of those people behind the
cameras all of those people who had made
it possible may Allah I'd like to ask
all the viewers to join us making Dua
for those individuals who don't work and
support for this cause for any name and
fame or recognition rather whether we
recognize them or not whether we
acknowledge that or not whether we even
notice their work or not we know deep
down in our heart Allah knows that and
nothing is hidden from Allah
Allah will reward you immensely in this
life in the year after my beloved for
all your work and support for this noble
cause that you have been doing in any
capacity in spite of your challenges and
difficulties you have been working in
this regard be it is in the midwest or
the West Coast or the East Coast
wherever you may have been in any shape
and form or internationally rest assure
whether you get recognized or your name
is being called or not Allah
knows that and his angels are taking in
account and you will have the great
reward in it insha Allah so thank you so
very much for all your support and
dedication and work for this Noble
working
and for those out there who have
generously supported this noble cause
and make this a reality the show to come
to this far may Allah reward you for all
the support that we have done be it is
financial or the encouraging words or
Dua that you have supported we need all
of that in order for us to continue to
work in this noble cause insha Allah
again I wanted to take opportunity for
those who we have not yet reach or for
those who we have not yet convinced
don't let our inability to convince you
the need and the importance of this
noble cause keep you from giving
generously for this efforts rather put
your trust in Allah and no it is your
responsibility to support this noble
cause and support us in Long disease to
deliver this message to the masses who
are desperately in need of this
beautiful being through the Deen Center
this is
thank you very much thank you very much
Dr Musa Imam Hafiz thank you so much for
being with us and everybody out there
we're coming to an end now and I want to
thank those people like uh my Musa was
saying behind the scenes people in the
front in the back everybody who's
contributed from the small to the big to
the medium and we know that at the end
of the day everything's gonna stay
behind and the guests over and over
reminded it's one of those things now
that you are having that investment
give back to you when you leave this
life inshallah will be doing that work
that important work that's supposed to
be done of inviting people to the
purpose of life establishing the school
in one of the buildings the Masjid the
Athletic Facility the dollar recording
studio and the list goes on and
inshallah you could be a part of History
you could be a part of this Legacy go
ahead and donate right now we'll see you
next time go ahead and make Dua that's
the least you could do you can share
this so other people can know more about
the project and we'll see you next time
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum